so
so
so
so
good morning dear colleagues can i ask
you to take your seats
dear colleagues good morning
can i ask you to take your seats please
yes
once again good morning
to all of you dear colleagues
first of all i am pleased
to welcome the president of the european
commission ursula van der lion to our
european parliament for the annual
state of the european union
address
it is also very much a special honor
to have olena zelenska with us on this
important day
[Applause]
dear elena we are with you
and with the ukrainian people we are
here today
against an alarming backdrop of an
illegal
unjustifiable invasion
of sovereign ukraine
high inflation electricity and energy
price rises
a climate catastrophe
increased food insecurity and a fast
emerging cost of living crisis
i think our message today will be that
europe
will respond
and to underline how we will do that it
is my pleasure to give the floor to the
president of the european commission to
deliver her 2022 state of the european
union address jerusalem the floor is
yours
[Applause]
thank you madam president honorable
members
my fellow europeans
never before
has this parliament debated the state of
our union
with war raging on european soil
and we all remember that fateful morning
in late february
europeans from across our union
woke up
dismayed by what they saw
shaken by the resurgent and ruthless
face of evil
haunted by the sounds of sirens and the
sheer brutality of war
but from that very moment on
a whole continent
has risen in solidarity
at the border crossings where refugees
found shelter
in our streets filled with ukrainian
flags
in the classrooms where ukrainian
children made new friends
from that very moment
europeans neither hid nor hesitated
they found the courage to do the right
thing
and from that very moment
our union as a whole
has risen to the occasion
15 years ago
during the financial crisis
it took us years to find lasting
solutions
a decade later when the global pandemic
hit it took us only weeks
but this year
as soon as russian troops
crossed the border into ukraine
our response was united
determined and immediate and i think we
can be proud of that
[Applause]
we have brought europe's inner strength
back to the surface
and we will need all this strength
the moments ahead of us
will not be easy
be it for the families who are
struggling to make ends meet
or businesses who are facing tough
choices concerning their future
and let us be very clear
much is at stake
not just for ukraine
but for all of europe and the world at
large
and we will be tested
tested by those
who want to exploit any kind of division
between us
and this is not only a war unleashed by
russia
against ukraine
this is also worn our energy
it's a war on our economy
it's a war on our values
it is a war on our future
it is about autocracy
against democracy
and i stand here with a conviction
that with the necessary courage
and with the necessary solidarity putin
will fail and ukraine and europe will
prevail
today
courage
has a name and that name is ukraine
courage has a face
and that face is the face of ukrainian
men and women
who are standing up
to the russian aggression
i remember a moment in the early weeks
of the invasion
when the first lady of ukraine
olena zelenska
gathered the parents
of ukrainian children
killed by the invader
hundreds of families
for whom the war will never end
and for whom life will never go back
to what it was before
we saw the first lady
leading a silent crowd of heartbroken
mothers and fathers
and hangs small bells in the trees one
for every fallen child
and now these bells will ring forever in
the wind
and forever
the innocent victims of this war will
live in our memories
and yes she's here with us today
my dear olena zelenska
it took immense courage to resist
putin's cruelty
but you found the courage
and a nation of heroes has risen
today in ukraine stands strong because
an entire country has fought street by
street and house by house
and we are seeing in the last days the
bravery of the ukrainians is paying off
ukraine stands strong because people
like your husband president zielenski
have stayed in keefe
to lead the resistance
together with you
and your children
you have given courage
to a whole nation
you have given a voice to your people on
a global stage
you have given hope to all of us
so today we want to thank you and all
ukrainians
glory to a country of european heroes
slava ukraine
europe's solidarity with ukraine will
remain unshakable
from day one on
europe has stood at ukraine's side
with weapons
with funds
with hospitalities for refugees
and with the toughest sanctions the
world has ever seen
russia's financial sector is on life
support
we have cut off three quarters of
russia's banking sector from
international markets
nearly 1 000 international companies
have left the country
the production of cars fell by 75
compared to last year
iro flood is grounding planes because
there are no more spare parts
the russian military is taking chips
from dishwashers and refrigerators
to fix their military hardware because
there are no semiconductors anymore
russia's industry is in tatters
and it is the kremlin
that has put russia's economy on the
path of oblivion
that is the price
for russians russia's and putin's trail
of death and destruction
and i want to make it very clear
the sanctions are here to stay this is
time for us for resolve and not for
appeasement this has to be very clear
the same is true for our financial
support for ukraine
so far team europe has provided more
than 19 billion euros in financial
assistance and this is without counting
the military support
and we are in for the long haul
ukraine's reconstruction will require
massive resources
for instance russian strikes have
damaged or destroyed more than 70
schools
half a million ukrainian children have
started their school year in the
european union but many other ukrainian
children simply do not have a classroom
to go to
and you told me yesterday dear elena
that every day when the parents are
sending the children to school
they don't only give them the school bag
but also an emergency bag with water
with food
with band-aids medical supply
with socks
and an underwear to change
and just imagine you send in the morning
your child to school handbag in to
school and you do not know whether
you're going to be reunited in the
afternoon after school so my dear olana
i am announcing that we will work with
you
to support the rehabilitation of damaged
ukrainian schools we will provide what
you need this is 100 million euros
because the future of ukraine begins in
the schools and with the children
we will not only support financially but
also empower ukraine to make the most of
its potential
ukraine has already a rising tech hub
and home is home to many
very young smart companies
so i want us to mobilize the full power
of our single market to help accelerate
growth and create opportunities
please remember in march we connected
successfully ukraine to our electricity
grid it was planned for 2024 we did it
in two weeks only
and today ukraine is exporting
electricity to the european union
so i want to significantly expand this
mutual beneficial trade we have already
suspended import duties on ukrainian
exports to ukraine
we will bring ukraine into our european
free roaming area it's really time to do
that now
our solidarity lines are big success and
building on all of that
the commission will work with ukraine to
go a step further and to ensure a
seamless access to the single market of
the european union our single market is
one of europe's greatest success stories
we know the power that lies in the
single market so now it is time to make
it a success story for our ukrainian
friends too and this is why today i'm
going to keefe to discuss all this with
president zelinski and to show him what
the single market is as a potential for
ukraine's future too
my honourable members
one lesson from this war is
we should have listened
to those who know putin
to anna politkovskaya
and all the russian journalists
who exposed the crimes
and paid the ultimate price
to our friends in ukraine moldova
georgia and the opposition in belarus
we should have listened to the voices
inside our union
in poland in the baltics and all across
central and eastern europe
they have been telling us for years
that putin would not stop
and they acted accordingly
our friends in the baltics have worked
hard to end their dependency on russia
they have invested heavily in renewable
energy in lng terminals in
interconnected
they made the experience yes this comes
at a cost but dependency on russian
fossil fuels comes at a much much higher
price
so we have to get rid
of this dependency over all over europe
as you know therefore we agreed to join
storage we are now at 84
that's good we're overshooting our
targets
but unfortunately this will not be
enough
we have to diversify away from russia
to su reliable suppliers like the united
states and norway and algeria and others
two figures that are interesting last
year
russian gas accounted for 40 percent of
our imported gas
today it's down to nine percent
but we also see that russia keeps
actively manipulating our energy market
i mean they prefer to flare the gas
instead of
sending it to europe according to the
contracts that are existing so this
market is not functioning anymore
and in addition
the climate crisis is heavily weighing
in our bills
heat waves have boosted electricity
demand
droughts shut down hydro and nuclear
plants
and as a result
prices have risen by more than 10 times
compared to before the pandemic
making ends meet is becoming a source of
anxiety
for millions of businesses and
households in the european union
but
we also see how europeans are coping
with this challenge
think of the workers in ceramic
factories in central italy
who have decided to move their shifts to
the early morning to benefit from the
lower energy prices and just imagine
the mothers and fathers among those
workers having to leave home early when
the kids are still sleeping because of a
war they have not chosen
this is one example in a million of
examples of europeans
adapting to the new reality
and i want our union to take example
from its people
so reducing demand
during peak hours
will make supply last longer and it will
bring prices down
this is why we're putting forward
measures
for member states to reduce their
overall electricity consumption
and then
targeted support is needed
for small and medium enterprises like
the glass makers across europe who
cannot longer turn on their ovens or for
single parents facing one daunting bill
after the next if they look at
electricity millions of europeans need
support
this is why we are proposing a cap on
the revenues of companies
that produce electricity at low costs
these companies are making revenues they
never accounted for
they never even dreamt of
and don't get me wrong in our social
market economy
profits are okay they are good
but
in these times it is wrong to receive
extraordinary record revenues and
profits
benefiting from war and on the back of
our consumers
in these times
profits must be shared
and channeled to those who need it most
and therefore our proposal also
includes the fossil fuel electricity
producers who have to give a crisis
contribution
and overall our proposal will raise more
than 140 billion euros for member states
to cushion the blow directly
these are all emergency and temporary
measures we are working on including our
discussion on gas price caps
we need to keep working on lower gas
prices
so on one hand we have to ensure the
security of supply
on the other hand we have to ensure
global competitiveness
the security of the ply because the gas
still has to come to the european union
the energy of all
on the other hand if it's too expensive
it's damaging our global competitiveness
so we will develop with the member
states a set of measures
to take into account the specific nature
of our relationship with suppliers
ranging from unreliable suppliers such
as russia
to reliable friends such as our
norwegian friends for example
i have agreed with prime minister store
to set up a task force so that the teams
work for this aim together to look how
are we able to lower
in a reasonable manner the price for gas
another important
topic is on the agenda
today our gas markets have changed
dramatically
from pipeline gas we used to have in
abundance mainly to increasing
amounts of lng gas
but the benchmark used in the gas market
the so-called ttf has not adapted
so this is why the commission will work
on establishing a more representative
benchmark
for the
electricity trading that really reflects
this change in the market we have seen
and at the same time we also know that
energy companies are facing severe
problems with liquidity
in electricity futures
markets we will work with the market
regulators
to ease these problems
by amending the rules on collaterals
and by taking measures
to limit the intraday price volatility
and we will amend the temporary state
aid framework in october
to allow for the provision of state
guarantees
while preserving a level playing field
this is very complex this is not at all
trivial but i must say these are only
the first steps
but because as we deal with immediate
crisis we must also look forward
and therefore
my diagnosis is the current electricity
market designed that is based on the
principle of merit order
is not fit for purpose anymore it's not
just for consumers anymore
consumers should reap the benefits
of low-cost renewables
that must be the purpose
so we have to decouple
the dominant influence of gas on the
price of electricity
and this is why we will do a deep and
comprehensive reform of the electricity
market
now honorable members there is one
important point
half a century ago
in the 1970s
the world faced another fossil fuel
crisis
some of us remember the car free weakens
to save energy
yet
we kept driving on the same road
we did not get rid of our defendancy on
oil
and worse
fossil fuels were even massively
subsidized
this was wrong
not just for the climate but also for
our public finances and for our
independence as we know today and we're
still paying the price for that
only a few visionaries understood
that the real problems
problem
was the fossil fuels themselves
not their price
and among them were our danish friends
when the oil crisis hit denmark started
to invest heavily into harnessing the
power of the wind
they laid the foundation
for its global leadership in the sector
and created tens of thousands of new
jobs this is the way to go
not just a quick fix
but a change of paradigm a leap into the
future and that must be our principle
today with this crisis too honorable
members
ladies and gentlemen members the good
news is that this necessary
transformation has already started it's
taking place in the north sea and in the
baltic
where member states have invested
massively in offshore wind
it's taking place in sicily
where the largest solar power plant in
europe will soon be producing
the latest generate generation of solar
panels
in northern germany
regional trains are now running on green
hydrogen
hydrogen can change the situation
completely for europe we have to move
from a niche market towards a mass
market for hydrogen
and with repower eu we have
redoubled their objectives we want to
produce 10 million tons of renewable
hydrogen by 2030.
to achieve that
we need to create
a
new hydrogen market to fill the
investment gap
and to match supply and demand for the
future
so today i will be announcing
that we have created a new
european hydrogen bank
this will help to guarantee
the uh
supply of hydrogen using money from the
innovation fund
it will be able to invest 3 billion
euros
to help to construct a future hydrogen
market
and that
is how we will build the economy of the
future
that is the green deal
[Applause]
over the last few months we've all seen
to what extent the green deal is
important
summer 2022 will remain in people's
memories
we've all seen the dried up rivers the
burning forests the extreme heat and the
situation is much worse than what we can
see
the alpine glaciers have been an
emergency reserve for rivers like the
rhone and the rhine
but as
europe's glaciers are melting faster
than expected future droughts will be
much more serious
we have to work tirelessly to adapt to
climate change and to make nature our
first ally
that's why our union will push for a
global agreement on nature that is
ambitious
when we go to the united nations
conference on biodiversity which will
take place in montreal this year
and we will do the same at the
cop 27 at charmel sheikh
but in the short term we also need to be
better equipped to face up to climate
change
no country can combat
the weather
on their own and the destructive force
of extreme weather events
this summer
we sent greek aeroplanes sweet swedish
aeroplanes
and italian airplanes
to combat fires in france and in germany
but these events are becoming more and
more frequent and more and more intense
europe needs more capacity
that's why today i announce that we will
double our capacity for firefighting
over the course of the coming year the
european union will buy 10
light aircraft
and three additional helicopters to
complete its fleet
that is european solidarity and practice
honourable members
the last years have shown how much
europe can achieve
when it is united
after an unprecedented pandemic
our economic output overtook pre-crisis
level in record time
we went from having no vaccines
to securing over four billion of these
live
saving vaccines for europeans and for
the whole world
and in record time we came up with sure
so that people could stay in their jobs
even if their companies had run out of
work
we were in the deepest recession since
world war ii
and we achieved the fastest recovery
since the post-war boom
and all that was possible
because we all rallied behind a common
recovery plan
next generation eu
has been a boost of confidence for our
economy and its journey has only just
begun
so far
100 billion euros have been disbursed
for member states to member states
this means 700 billion euros still
haven't flown into our economy
next generation you will guarantee a
constant stream of investment to sustain
jobs and growth
it means relief for our economy
but most importantly
it means renewal
it is financing new wind turbines and
solar parks high speed train and
energy-saving renovations
we conceived next generation eu almost
two years ago and yet
it is still exactly what europe needs
today so let's stick to the plan and
bring the money to the ground it has to
be delivered because it's necessary now
as investment
and honorable members
the future of our children
needs both
that we invest in sustainability
but also that we invest sustainably
we must finance the transition to a
digital and net zero economy
and yet
we also have to acknowledge a new
reality
of higher public debt
we need fiscal rules
that allow for strategic investment
while safeguarding fiscal sustainability
rules that are fit for the challenges of
this decade
and therefore in october we will come
forward with new ideas
for our economic governance
let me share few basic principles with
you
member states should have more
flexibility
on their debt reduction path
but there should be more accountability
on the delivery
of what we have agreed on
there should be simpler rules that all
can follow
to open the space for strategic
investments we need it
and to give the financial markets the
confidence they need
so let us chart once again a joint way
forward
with more freedom to invest that's
necessary
more scrutiny on the process what has
been agreed has to be done
more ownership by member states and
better results for the citizens so in
short
let's rediscover the mastery spirit
stability and growth can only go hand in
hand
because honorable members as we embark
on this transition
in our economy
we must rely
on the enduring values of the social
market economy
it's the beautiful simple idea that
europe's greatest strength
lies in each and every one of us our
social market economy encourages
everyone to excel
but it also takes care of the fragility
as human beings
it covers the big risks of life
like poverty
sickness age
it rewards performance
and guarantees protection
it opens opportunities
but it also sets limits
and we need this today even more than
ever
because the strength of our social
market economy
will drive the between and the digital
transition
and our accolades heal
for the small and medium enterprises are
basically three things
it's do we have an enabling business
environment
it's the question do we have a workforce
with the right
skills and do we have access to raw
materials our industry need
this will be the three crucial questions
to answer right now to have
a future
with the model as with as i've described
right now
we must for our smes remove the
obstacles that still hold them back
they must be at the center of this
transformation because they are the
backbone of our industry and europe's
long history of industrial prowess
and they have always put their employees
first even and especially in times of
crisis
but inflation
and uncertainty are weighings especially
hard on them
this is why
we will put forward
an sme relief package
it will include a proposal
for a single set of tax rules for doing
business in europe
called be fit
it will make it easier to do business in
our union
less red tape
better access to the dynamism of our
continental market
and honourable members it is high time
that we revise the late payment
directive
because it's simply not fair
that one in four bankruptcies that's 25
of all bankruptcies are due to invoices
not being paid in time this can't be
possible for millions of family
businesses we have to revise this late
payment directive this will be a
lifeline in troubled watches
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen members
the second big topic is the lack of
staff for our companies that's a major
challenge for european companies
the number of uh unemployed
has never been so low 6.0 percent six
percent unemployment that's a good thing
but at the same time the number of
unfilled vacancies is at record levels
hgv drivers airport staff nurses
engineers i.t technicians
right from unskilled levels to the
highest university degrees we need
people at all levels
and we need to invest more in
further education and higher education
we need a cl careful knowledge of what
staff are needed and how we can fill
those vacancies we need to combine
that with the wishes of the workers for
their own careers
we've got the esf that's a great
instrument and at the same time we need
a structure that ensures that the money
is effectively used
and there's another important point
we need to
get qualified staff from abroad that can
strengthen europe's growth so an
important step is to ensure that these
people can get their qualifications
recognized more rapidly in europe
that's one way to make europe more
attractive for everyone who's got skills
and that want to be part of europe
so i propose
that the year 2023
should be europe's
uh
year of education and training
that is the right priority it's a step
forward
members ladies and gentlemen third point
that's very important
uh small and medium-sized companies all
of our industrial sector
well it doesn't matter
whether we're talking
about uh
chips and
augmented reality
storage for for solar power facilities
but access to commodities to raw
materials is decisive for the success of
our transformation to a sustainable and
digital economy
lithium and rare earths
are going to be
more important soon than oil and gas are
today
our needs for raw earths alone so rare
earths alone will be multiplied
five-fold by 2030.
i think this just shows how rapidly
we're moving forward on the european
green deal the problem
is
that at the moment there's just one
country that almost completely controls
the entire market
we need to avoid finding ourselves stuck
in dependence
of the kind of dependence that we now
see with oil and gas
a lot of steps must be taken
on that front but trade policy comes
into question there we need new
partnerships
geographically
these
raw materials are not just located in
one place on earth
we need
new partnerships not just to strengthen
our economy but also to pursue our
interests and values at the global level
with similarly minded partners we can
work beyond our borders to improve labor
and environmental conditions
we need new reliable partners
where we can mutually grow
the agreement with chile mexico and new
zealand will be put forward for
ratification
and we will continue negotiations with
partners like australia and india we
need to learn from the mistakes of the
past
ice is only a first step
the processing
of these metals is just as critical
and today
china controls the global global
processing industry
almost 90 percent 90
of rare earth and 60 of lithium are
processed in china
so we will identify strategic projects
all along the supply chain from
extracting to refining from processing
to recycling
and we will build up strategic reserves
where supply is at risk
this is why today
i am announcing a european critical raw
materials act
we know that this approach can work
because remember
five years ago
europe launched the batteries alliance
and soon
two-thirds of the batteries we need we
will produce here in europe that's a big
success story
last year announced the european ships
act
and the first chips gigafactory will
break ground in the coming months
so we now need to replicate this success
for raw materials
and this is also why we will increase
our financial participation
in the important projects of common
european interests the so-called ipceis
and for the future
i will push
to create a new european sovereignty
fund
because we have to make sure
that the future of the industry is made
in europe
honourable members
as we look around
at the state of the world today
it can often feel like
there is a fading away
what once seemed so permanent
and in some ways
the passing of queen elizabeth ii
last week
reminded us
all of that
she
is a legend
she was a constant throughout the
turbulent and transforming events in the
last 70 years
stoic
and steadfast in her service
but more than anything
she always found the right words for
every moment in time
from the call she made to war evacuees
in 1940
to her historic address during the
pandemic
she spoke not only to the heart
of her nation
but to the soul of the whole world
and when i think of the situation we're
in today
her words at the height of the pandemic
still resonate with me she said
we will succeed
and that success will belong to every
one of us
end of quote
she always reminded us that our future
is built on new ideas and founded in our
oldest values
since the end of world war ii
we have pursued the promise
of democracy and of the rule of law
and the nations of the world have built
together an international system
promoting peace and security justice and
economic progress
today
this is the very target of russian
missiles
what we saw in the streets streets of
bucha in the scorched fields of green
and now in the gates of ukraine's
largest nuclear plant
is not only a violation of international
rules it is the deliberate attempt to
discard them once and for all that we
have to know
and this watershed moment
in global politics
calls for rethink
of our foreign policy agenda
this is to the time to invest in the
power of our democracies
this work begins with a core group of
our like-minded partners
our friends in every single democratic
nations on the globe
we see the world with the same eyes
we share the same values and we should
mobilize our collective power to shape
global goods
we should strive to expand the core of
these
democracies the most immediate way to do
this is to deepen our ties
and strengthen democracies on our
continent
this starts with those
that are already on the path to our
union
we must be at their side by every step
and every day
because the path towards strong
democracies and the path towards our
union are one and the same and so i want
to know the people of the western
balkans ukraine moldova and georgia to
know and i think i speak in the name of
this noble house
you are part of our family you are the
future of our union and in our union and
our union is not complete without you
this has to be the message
[Applause]
and we have seen that there is a need to
reach out to other countries of europe
beyond the accession process this is why
i support the call for european
political community
and we will set out our ideas to the
european council
but our future also depends on our
ability to engage beyond the core of our
democratic partners
countries near and far
share an interest in working with us
on the greatest challenges of this
century such as climate change and
digitalization
and this is the main idea behind global
gateway the investment plan i announced
last year right at this place
it is already delivering on the ground
together with our african partners we're
building two factories in ronda and
senegal to manufacture mrna vaccines
so they will be made in africa for
africa with
class technology
and we are now replicating this approach
across latin america
as a part of a larger engagement
strategy that has to pick up now
urgently
all this requires investment on a global
scale
so we will team up with our friends
in the united states and our friends
in the g7 partners to make this happen
in this spirit
president biden and i will convene a
leaders meeting
to review and announce implementation
projects for this investment
honorable members
this is part of our work of
strengthening our democracies
but
we should not lose sight
of the way
foreign autocrats
are targeting our own countries
foreign entities are funding
institutions and institutes that
undermine our values
the disinformation is spreading from the
internet into the halt of our
universities
earlier this year the university of
amsterdam
shut down an allegedly independent
research center
which was actually funded by chinese
entities
and this center was publishing so-called
research on human rights
dismissing the evidence of forced labour
camps for eurygors as rumors
these lies are toxic for our democracies
and let's think about this we introduced
legislation to screen foreign direct
investment in our companies for security
reasons that's correct that's good that
we did it
but if we do that for our economy
shouldn't we do the same for our values
we need to better shield ourselves
from line interference
and this is why we will present
a defense of democracy pact
it will bring forward
covert foreign influence
it will shed the light
on
shady funding
we will not allow any autocracies trojan
horses to attack our democracies from
within
for more than 70 years our continent has
marched towards democracy
but the gains of our long journey are
not assured
and many of us have taken democracy for
granted for too long
especially those who like me
who have never experienced what it means
to live under the fist
of an authoritarian regime
today we all see that we must fight for
our democracies
every single day
every single minute
we must protect them both from the
external threats they face
but also from the vice that corrode them
from within
it is my commission's duty and the most
noble role to protect the rule of law
so let me assure you
we will keep insisting on judicial
independence
and we will make sure that we protect
our budget through the conditionality
mechanism
and today i would like to focus on
corruption with all its faces
the face of foreign agents trying to
influence
our political system
the face of shady companies or
foundations abusing public money
if we want to be credible when we ask
candidate countries to strengthen their
democracies
we must also eradicate corruption at
home
and this
and this is why in the coming year the
commission will present measures to
update our legislative framework for
fighting corruption
we will raise standards on offenses such
as
illicit enrichment
trafficking in influence
abuse of power beyond the more classic
offenses such as bribery
and we will also propose to include
corruption
in our human rights sanctions regime
our new tool to protect our values
abroad
honorable members our founders
only meant to lay the first stone of
this democracy
they always thought that future
generation would complete their work and
that's true we have to do that it's an
ongoing process
democracy has not gone out of fashion
but it must update itself
in order to keep improving people's
lives
you will remember these words
these are the words of our friend david
zasoli
a great european
democracy has not gone out of fashion
but it must update itself in order to
keep improving people's lives
david sausali thought that europe should
always look for new horizons
and through the adversity of these times
we have started to see
what our new horizon might be
a braver union
close to its people in times of needs
bolder in responding to historic
challenges and the daily concerns of our
european
and to work at their site when they deal
with the big trials of life
this is why the conference on the future
of europe was so important it was a
sneak peek of a different kind of
citizens engagement well beyond election
day
and after europe listened to its
citizens voice we now need to deliver
the citizens panels
that were central to the conference
will now become a regular feature of our
democratic life
and in the letter of intent that i have
sent today to president mitzola and
prime minister fjallem
i have outlined a number of proposals
for the year ahead that stem from the
conference of a conference on the future
they include for example a new
initiative
on mental health
we should take much better care
of our friends and partners and beloved
ones
and for many who are burdened with
anxiety
and who are lost
appropriate
accessible accessible that's so
important and affordable support
can be life-saving we know that this
support is not there today excessive
affordable and appropriate support
so we have to make sure with proposals
on mental health that we really improve
in this subject it is for some of our
fellow europeans life-saving
honorable members
democratic institutions must constantly
gain and regain the citizens trust
just like europeans did
when millions of ukrainians come
knocking on their door
what we saw
wasn't is
europe at its best
a union of determination and solidarity
but this determination and drive for
solidarity
is still missing
in our migration debate
our actions towards ukrainian refugees
must not be an exception
they can be a blueprint for going
forward
we need fair and quick procedures
a system that is crisis proof
and quick to deploy
and a permanent and legally binding
mechanism that ensures solidarity
and at the same time we need effective
control of our external borders in line
with the respect of fundamental rights
i want a europe that manages migration
with dignity and respect
i want to europe where all member states
take responsibility for the challenges
we all share
i want to europe that shows solidarity
to all member states
we have progress on the pact we now have
the road map and we now need the
political will to move forward and to
match
honourable members
three weeks ago
i had an incredible opportunity of
joining
1
500 young people
from all over europe
and all over the world
that gathered in tz
they have very different views
they come from
very different countries they speak
different languages they have different
backgrounds
and yet
there's something that connects them
they share a set of values and ideals
they believe in these values they are
determined to reach them
they are passionate about something that
is larger than themselves
and this generation is a phenomenal
generation it's a generation of dreamers
and makers
and in my last state of the union
i told you that i would like europe to
look more like these young people
we should put their aspirations
at the heart of everything we do
and the place for this
is in our founding treaties
every action that our union takes should
be inspired by a very simple principle
that we should do no harm to our
children's future
and that we should leave the world a
better place for the next generation
and therefore honorable members
i believe that it is time to enshrine
solidarity between generations
in our treaties
it is time to renew the european promise
and we also need to improve the way we
do things and the way we decide things
some might say this is not the right
time but if we are serious about
preparing for the world of tomorrow
we must be able to act on the things
that matter the most for people
and as we are serious about a larger
union we also have to be serious about
reform
so as this parliament has called for
i believe the moment has arrived for
european convention
honourable members
they say
light shines brightest in the dark
and that was certainly true for the
women and the children fleeing russia's
bombs
they fled
a country at war
filled with sadness for what they had
left behind and fear
for what
may lie ahead
but they were received with open hearts
and open arms
by many many citizens like magdalena
and agnieszka
two selfless young women from poland
as soon as they heard about trains full
of refugees
they rushed to the warsaw central
station
they started to organize they set up a
tent to assist as many people as
possible they reached out to supermarket
chains for food and to local authorities
to organize buses to hospitality centers
in a matter of days they gathered 3 000
volunteers to welcome refugees 24 7.
honorable members
magdalena and agneshka are here with us
today
please stand up
magdalena stand up
stand up
[Applause]
their stories about everything our union
stands and strives for it is story of
heart character and solidarity
they showed everyone
what europeans can achieve when we rally
around a common cause
this is europe spirit a union that
stands strong together
a union that prevails together
long live europe thank you
thank you uh very much
dear president here ursula i now move
to the reactions by
the political groups starting with the
leader of the epp group mumford brother
but i'm president of the european
parliament madame president of the
european commission
ramselensky
czech presidency dear colleagues
last week the hemi cycle in brussels was
full with
young people we organized the cpp group
a youth week at the beginning of the
autumn session in during
the discussion eva meidel a young
colleague of ours spoke about the moving
encounter during summer she was in
bulgaria in a supermarket checkout and
there was a young lady
she didn't speak very well bulgarian she
talked with her and was a ukraine
refugee
young talented
she was excited to start her university
studies and then
war fleeing losing loved ones she was
from mario paul and ending up in
uncertainty
that is the brutal reality of putin's
war
and on the other hand in my constituency
i received a letter from a small bakery
after decades of baking bavarian bread
he wrote to me he cannot survive at the
high energy costs the baker told me
putin is a war criminal no doubt about
this but how can i survive
these two stories marks the challenge in
front of us
and our epp answer is
we need
a winter of solidarity solidarity first
of all with ukraine more weapons more
money
more solidarity putin must lose ukraine
must win great news from ukraine that
they are pushing back their russian
troops from their soil and madame
zelensky we admire what your soldiers
are doing there on the front line thank
you for this
and your friends
solidarity among europeans nobody left
behind we care for the poor in our
societies and help our economies
especially the smes
crisis times means now leadership and
the epp supports the proposal of the
commission presented today on support
for ukraine but also to give an answer
on the soaring energy prices
but there is more to do
the markets the ladies and gentlemen are
obviously speculating against european
solidarity when winter will really be
hard let's be concrete
it is not normal in a market that
schultz has to call macron to open a gas
pipeline and we will be more independent
if spain would be better connected to
the european gas market and dear friends
if it is true that the winter will be
hard then we must use all our energy
resources
germany cannot stop producing nuclear
electricity and on the other hand ask
the dutch to ask for gas solid directly
that's not the case
and let's be honest
it was a lost it was a lost summer the
epp has been asking for an extraordinary
counseling meeting to give certainty to
structure things to show everyone that
we are united and you cannot split up
europe and the signal would have had
already lowered the prices people are
paying because politics wasn't is for
the moment among member states not
strong enough
and dear friends on inflation
not only driven by energy first it's an
ecb task that's clear
but i think we also can contribute one
example we have a global food crisis and
that is also increasing the prices for
our citizens
and the commission is now presenting new
regulations which will limit food
production in europe and produce more
bureaucratic burden for our farmers
for new legislation the commission
promised the principle of one in
and one out if we continue like this
then at the end of the mandate we will
arrive to five in and only one out dear
friends we have war in europe and parts
of the brussels community are continuing
to make new laws in new burdens as
nothing has happened that's why we as
epp group are asking for a moratorium on
new legislation let our business
especially the smes do their work
without burdening them
and for creating growth and having a
recession now in mind via cpp stand for
creating a
union of democratic economies on global
level
europe is a trading continent and if you
want to limit our dependency on the
autocracies on china and others and that
is the lesson we learned out of the
russian gas war then we must speed up on
trade deals with other democracies and
as epp we always did so but i just want
to remind ourselves about ceceta debate
in this house where the left greens and
part of the socialists were opposing to
doing a trade deal with canada
canada dear friends you frightened you
frightened europeans with misleading
arguments and even with lies and until
now schultz and macron are not ready to
ratify ceta on national level but they
are great in doing pictures with tridor
that is not serious dear friends that is
not serious
and about democracies yes madam
president you spoke about defending rule
of law and with you as commission
president and i have to say also in
poland with friends like donald tusk vs
epp we are fighting for rule of law you
stopped the money as epp president of
the commission to poland and hungary
that's why we are very very proud about
this rule of law must be judged and
based on clear criterias fair procedure
and must be blind like justice without
looking at party books
and speaking about democracies i have to
come back to the energy proposals and
madame president we spoke about this
you have our full support on the
procedure
but on the on the content but on the
procedure i have to say
uh we have to respect the european
parliament as a people's chamber can you
imagine a windfall tax and a price cap
being decided on national level without
the vote in the national parliament we
would call this a democratic problem
but now we have proposals on the table
who are doing this on europe and that
should not be the new normal on european
level so decisions without the european
parliament should not be the new normal
in europe and that's why please consider
again the legal base for the proposals
on the tape table the epp stands for a
democratic party europe and that means a
europe where all legislation is voted in
this chamber and then finally
finally during the covet crisis
dear friends we
we were ready for doing bigger steps
crrf proposed by wasella fonda line is
bigger than the marshall plan was so we
changed the architecture of europe that
was great
but today
war is back in europe there was no
council meeting on coordinating our
defense activities
only words there is no initiative to
stop universe vote on foreign affairs
only a speech from chancellor schultz in
prague
no convention to strengthen the european
democrats requested by this chamber and
the conference for the future of europe
only i have to say campaigning and
campaigning in paris the commission has
to launch now until december a european
defense action plan as a concrete
initiative in this field to invest
together to build up a european missile
defense system and the cyber brigade to
make europe stronger on this and we need
and thanks for your clear statement a
convention now
epp stands for a more ambitious europe
the times of sunday speeches are over
europe will be not saved by university
pulpit speeches but by political
leadership and the ukraine refugee in
bulgaria and mybaker they believe in
this and they understand this that's why
leadership
and leadership now
thank you very much
manfred i now give the floor to iracia
garcia perez chair of the snd group
gracias president
thank you president metzola president
fonte lyon
czech presidency
i'd like to start with some word of
thanks to magdalena and yeshka
for your commitment your solidarity
but above all
because you're a clear
example of the history of europe
europe who has always
shown uh
welcomes to people who've always opened
their arms to those who are fleeing war
and hunger
europe who wanted to demonstrate that
solidarity is one of their values
a a mixed europe
a multiple europe
europe uh that we remain extremely proud
of so thank you
it's very difficult to
assess the state of the union without
repeating the words that we've been
saying for a very long time now we're
facing historic challenges
we saw that in the coved pandemic and
we're now facing challenges with the war
that was started by vladimir putin who
is threatening our values and the
international balance
that's why it's so important that we
maintain our unity and we
strengthen our commitment to freedom and
the integrity of ukraine and at the same
time we have to act quickly with
ambition and solidarity
in order to
reduce the social and economic effects
of this war
you just have to go to the supermarket
to see that the typical shopping basket
prices are increasing every day
measures have been taken to contain
inflation but the price of food and
energy are increasing with no limit the
european central bank has increased the
cost of capital but this means
that mortgages are going up
without even referring to heating bills
ladies and gentlemen this is the state
of our union let's be clear
being clear however doesn't mean that we
should be pessimistic nor fatalistic
we're here to find solutions to try to
find solutions which do exist
we also have to ensure that we have the
political will to implement those
solutions as always crises
make our weaknesses clear but they also
show us where we need to act we have to
strengthen our social policies we form
the energy market reform fiscal and
economic governance
and to accelerate the green transition
uh we can't leave it too late
our commitment to the ukrainian people
is clear
however to get the support of the
european citizens we don't just have to
celebrate military victims we also have
to ensure that we put ourselves in the
shoes of those who are suffering from
this war including those in the european
union because without that we're going
to see a backlash against the war as
well as populism and extreme uh the
extreme right president vanderlian
we have always been loyal partners
during the pandemic and we will be again
now to tackle this crisis and to avoid
recession
it's late in the day but i'm very happy
that finally we are seeing a reaction
and that you have listened to the
proposals that have been made for this
by the socialists and democrats by a
long time now we have to cap gas prices
and help families and businesses to make
sure they can pay their bills to do that
we have to do that partially with the
extraordinary windfall profits of the
energy companies everyone has to do
their bit it's not fair that those who
some people have difficulty reaching the
end of the month and yet others are
profiting from the suffering of these
families
we are not
the center of the world i've just come
back from latin america and this should
be a priority for the union at the
moment it's not i was happy to hear
madame vandalian refer to
latin america
it shows that we need more cooperation
latin america is a natural ally in the
global order we have to be more present
more present there and not leave a void
that can be filled by other powers
i'm um
concerned by the rise of the extreme
right
uh we have to stand firm on the rule of
law and
the um commission of wonderland is the
guarantor of principles and the treaties
we have to be very clear and firm on
this
to conclude leaving aside institutional
issues i want to talk about the uh
political situation that we're facing at
the moment i'm saddened to have to say
this but the state of our democracy at
this historic moment
i think is just as fragile as our
economy
ghosts we thought had were in the past
are coming back
some member states are becoming
autocracies such as hungary under orban
and other
pro-fascist
parties can win electricities this is
dangerous and worrying mr webber members
of the epp i'm standing here
urging you to reconsider your role in
the european project
after the second world war
the founders of christian democracy
understood that the best example of
patriotism was to work
uh for the common interest of the whole
of the european union
together with social democracy
not an exclusive nationalism
i see that you are losing your way and
normalizing the entry of the extreme
right into these institutions i hope you
will put this right
i hope that you'll find
your way
because we have a shared responsibility
europe is counting on us
thank you
thank you miss garcia perez now on
behalf of the renew europe group the
chess stephan
[Music]
thank you madam president
president
200 days now for 200 days now the
european the ukrainian people has been
fighting the russian aggression
aggressor for 200 days they've been
fighting for their freedom and for our
freedom
their struggle is ours it is the
struggle of democracy against or
autocracy the struggle of the rule of
law against the law of the strongest
it's the freedom against depression our
union against its enemies
the last few months we've held the line
all together
but now the populists are coming up with
very dangerous proposals war isn't just
sanctions but
these this war is having consequences on
the daily lives of our citizens the
quantity of energy the quantity of uh
food available maybe in future the jobs
available in europe we need to respond
rapidly and well ru europe can be
effective and your speech
madame van der lion it proves this your
proposals are good and i'd like to thank
you for the democratic exercise that you
have just end
just embarked upon
all of these
projects are ones that we support
and particularly on the main front we
face which is the energy front
we're in favor of a european energy
shield to reduce bills
and i think there are even two forms of
european solidarity
european solidarity with europe's
citizens and smes using the windfall
profits from the energy companies and
setting a cap on gas imports
the second form of solidarity is
solidarity between the member states and
our neighbours
we need to make joint purchases of
energy
we need
to invest surpluses into investing in
renewables and
renovation of buildings that is an
objective for our group
we want to make our continent the first
one to abandon fossil fuels
but out on the extremes there are these
uh
very
glib solutions they say get rid of the
sanctions as if the sanctions were the
cause of europe's problems
even if
russia's gdp has fallen by six percent
the
uh russian army is trying to get
resupplies by koran sorry iran and north
korea
we've received information yesterday
about the kinds of huge figures 300
million euros that have been sent to
european political parties in europe and
abroad to carry out interference
the european parliament should deal with
this the institutions should deal with
this
there are proposals against foreign
intervention in europe our group
supports those proposals we need to work
harder on this
because it's a democratic challenge
primarily the other main issue is
sovereignty
sovereignty means that we should reduce
all of our dependencies well in the food
sector i could
just mention that
there is
we can't risk a breakdown in food
supplies we need to work upstream
on raw materials health digital sector
infrastructure defense
my group is in favor of a new action
plan to identify our vulnerabilities and
to try and
reinforce our value chains within europe
as a union every single question we need
to be asking ourselves this question and
a parliamentarians in particular will
the decision we're taking make us more
sovereign or more dependent
we propose a sovereignty test to in test
this conformity of the whole european
aqui of the any new european legislation
that we have put together between the
parliament and commission we need to
check our budgetary lines our
investments for the future in line with
the sovereignty test
now
all of our public policies have to be
aligned with the strategic autonomy
objective
that's the only way to ensure that the
eu is not just an economic power but a
geopolitical power and that's something
that you stressed before this uh plenary
at the beginning of your term in office
we need to guarantee
equality
and quality of life for our citizens
economic growth the green transition and
our place in the world all of these
proposals raise a fundamental question
for our institution on budgetary
framework the union has shown
that it can show agility and flexibility
over the last few months
but the question is
not just the question of the convention
that you're putting forward
first of all
when we'll be able to
well how long we'll be able to continue
deciding things by unanimity and at what
price
and then if we are to invest together we
need to know what priorities we're
picking out
that's
what we need to know before we launch a
convention
that is uh
what we need to know before we go before
the council
we have been among the first to call for
a conference on the future of europe
calling for a review of our budget
and a convention can follow that up i'm
sure that you'll find that my group's
position is clear and will not surprise
you
and i'm sure
you won't be surprised that i raised the
rule of law
the rule of law has to be our compass
it has to guide our actions beyond our
borders and within the european union
i thinking particularly of mr orban
now for 10 years
we've been looking the other way
this indifference
has led to corruption and discrimination
spreading wildly in the country the
media has
under state control and spread russian
proper
propaganda there are problems elsewhere
too in poland in particular which is a
very different case but all of these
this kind of backsliding has to be
combated
other countries are moving into unknown
democratic terrain such as italy we need
to hold firm madam president
we are counting upon you we are counting
upon all of the college of commissioners
multiple crisis bringing out that the
the approach that you took in 2019 is
the right one
the transition
democracy
renew is proud of what we've already
been able to achieve we've got through
these crises and we will give you our
support for concluding the projects that
you've put forward to us
we shall not hesitate
we shall not delay
and we shall
not
forget how important it is for us to
work together in this new international
situation i think we are up to the
challenge madam president
i give the floor now to scar keller the
heart of the green group
dear commission president dear
colleagues and dear mr lenska it's a big
honor that you are here with us today
and your presence reminds us
that while we talk a lot about the
problems that we're facing in the eu the
real consequences of this war of
aggression of putin are carried by the
people in ukraine
a brutal invasion
a brutal invasion led against the
peaceful people of ukraine simply
because they chose to live in freedom
and democracy and putin cannot live with
the fact that people live in liberty
with human and civil rights and that
nations work together peacefully freedom
and democracy
principles the eu was founded on are the
biggest threats to him
and all together we must face this
atrocious aggression with determination
and with courage just as ukraine is
showing us europe needs to support and
continue to support ukraine in their
fight for peace and self-determination
and even scale up those efforts and the
past days have shown that the ukrainian
people are able to resist the attack and
it is now that europe needs to stand by
their side by your side
while ukraine
while ukraine suffers most from the
attack there is also consequences for
the eu
we must be prepared for tough times
ahead to do that we must show solidarity
to the outside but also to the inside by
ensuring that the costs and consequences
are carried by the stronger shoulders in
our society
with a skyrocketing energy and food
crisis we must act
we know that many citizens in our union
are fearful of what the winter will
bring
fearful of being unable to heat their
homes feed their children pay their
bills
and we cannot turn a blind eye to the
situation of the most vulnerable people
in our union already now
every fifth person in the eu lives in
poverty and the scale of the increasing
prices means that many more households
will be at risk it is our duty to ensure
that people who are struggling get
support and that the greed and profits
of a few don't lead to misery of many
so let's take bold policy steps
to make sure that everyone gets through
these tough times and i welcome the
commission president's proposal to skim
off windfall profits from energy
companies something that we that we as
greens if a group have been calling for
since the beginning of this crisis
the only true way to end our energy
dependency is on the one hand to use
less energy and on the other hand to
produce more renewable energy
sun and wind provide us with much more
power than we could ever possibly use so
let's profit from that
fossil fuels have been a driver for
ecological disaster and for dangerous
dependency renewables are the true
catalyzers for peace security and
stability
now is the time to scale up investments
into renewables to put solar and every
roof insulate buildings and make sure
sun and wind carry us into a new era of
sustainable and affordable european
energy production
and let's make no mistake commission
president and colleagues the climate
crisis is probably the biggest political
political test for our generation
all over europe we experience the
devastation the climate crisis is
bringing and will bring to our continent
and to the world
this summer massive droughts and reef
heat waves have paid the waves have
paved the way for wildfires
killing a substantial amount of our
harvest as well and led to thousands of
deaths that came prematurely
the cost of non-action
is immense
it is time to act and to quickly build a
brighter cleaner future to capitalize on
the enormous potential that the green
transition brings in terms of
sustainable economic development
well-paying and future-proof jobs
cleaner air and but better quality of
life for our citizens
dear colleagues the commission president
putin's war against ukraine is also
targeted at our eu values and at
democracy
in order to stand strong against
opponents and threats we have to defend
those values within the eu and without
exception
and i'm grateful
i'm grateful for your strong words on
rule of law commission president however
we have heard very promising words
before what we're lacking is action
thanks to parliament we have instruments
at hand but now they need to be used
including the rule of law conditionality
dear commissioner president please
respect the conditionality instrument
and the political will of this
parliament no money should be given to
the governments of poland and hungary
unless they clearly return to the path
of rule of law
and i want to tell our dear colleagues
from the epp and especially to you mr
weber be careful whom you form
partnerships with
looking at italy you are playing a risky
game
with democracy and with our shared
values just for power a game that could
backfire
for all of us
a group that claims to be part of the
democratic majority should not partner
with people who wear poutine fancy
shirts nor parties with fascist logos
not in italy not in spain not in sweden
not in the ep nowhere and never
and
it is a bit awkward that i say this as a
green
but the center right as a very important
role to play in europe
and part of this together with all of us
is to ward off the extreme right and if
you open the door to them you are doing
a big big disservice to europe but i
believe also to your own party
dear commission president and dear
colleagues yes the state of union is
full of challenges stemming from the war
in ukraine to the rule of law to the
climate crisis we are facing a big test
however
i am convinced that the eu has the
strength to face these challenges if we
work together
work to work work together towards the
new energy independence a climate
neutral continent and maybe most
importantly for european union that
deserves and maintains the trust of our
european citizens founded on values
founded on solidarity
thank you very much
thank you miss keller and now
i give the flaw
to the chair of the id group marco zanni
on a revelato
grazie
president
thank you
president madam zelenska
welcome
it's important that you are here today
and what's also important is that today
we have heard that in this institution
in this uh chamber
there is a full uh transversal support
for ukraine against
russia and that will continue
before i go into the
topic that madame van der lion raised i
would like to
make a suggestion to our green and
socialist friends
given that they have uh no new ideas
they continue to warn against the threat
of fascism in europe
you just have to speak to citizens to
businesses
i would i can promise you that none of
them are concerned about a fascist
threat what they are concerned about is
that they are having to deal with the
damage caused by years of devastating
policies that have been put forward by
these groups in europe
now on what uh president vandalian has
said
it was
a nice speech that we listened to but
unfortunately
uh president it is merely a speech it's
just words
you said that the commission is going to
be putting forward some measures to try
to face up to this tragic situation um
one like this continent has never
experienced
but these measures if i may
are far from being enough
to
bring
genuine support to uh the blameless
people who are suffering because of this
tragic situation
businesses are closing
production is stopping
shops are shutting
and citizens
can no longer
make ends meet
because the cost of living is increasing
exponentially across europe
and now as you said it's true that the
main
blame for this does not lie in europe
but the unjustified aggression that
we've seen but since the 24th of
february europe has been responsible for
protecting its own citizens against the
consequences that we could all imagine
and that we were all aware
from the beginning
uh could arise
uh europe can be blamed for not having
acts quickly enough
you just recently said that democracy
has a price if we want democracy then
there are certain
procedures that we have to
[Music]
follow
dialogue discussion
then action however this cannot be used
um as a pretext for not acting and for
not taking uh the responsibility that
lies with european institutions
gas price caps
is the only measure that may somewhat
help our citizens and businesses against
the crisis that they are experiencing
but yet this remains something that is
merely rhetoric it remains merely words
it's just
uh discussed but it's discussed in terms
that does not give hope to those people
who are suffering all too clearly
because of the crisis
they are crying out for help
people are asking for rapid action
and in light of that i would like to
make another comment uh reflecting more
on the uh internal mechanisms of the
european union
and picking up on something that you've
been saying since 2019
in my country we say that only stupid
people can't change their minds
i think the european commission has to
look at how many proposals uh all
from the pillars of the 2019 programs
and look at what needs to be changed
what needs to be reviewed if you look at
the world uh since 2019 since these
plans and programs were put together the
world has changed entirely
and we know that that world
is not going to come back we're not
going to go back in time so on the green
deal and other
trade policies europe and the commission
are going to have to be pragmatic and
look at the fact that the situation is
different you need to have a long sight
of view
and understand that conditions have
changed
and that
some plans cannot be implemented anymore
these plans have not helped to protect
the climate they have not helped with an
economic socioeconomic or
industrial transition and that's what we
need so desperately right now thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much president
president vandalian
on behalf of the ecr group i would also
like to wish a warm welcome and
offer my full support to mrs zelinska
at this moment in time it's important
that we send out a clear message from
this plenary for support to ukraine
your state of the union address this
year is probably the most difficult one
that you have made in recent years the
context
is very complex not only because of
what's happening in the present days but
because we have a difficult period
behind us first the pandemic and then
the outbreak of war
so i think it's important that in these
circumstances we need to clearly
condemn the actions of russia and the
behavior of russia
we have full support and solidarity in
facts and in words with ukraine in our
everyday actions on behalf of the
government and the european institutions
it's very important to work hard right
now because the issue of uh europe's
defense and foreign affairs policy has
to be transformed particularly with the
transatlantic alliance where we need to
bolster
the relationship with europe's countries
we now
need to provide full support to the
difficult
path that we have taken on sanctions
only sanctions can bring results
and
at the same time
we need to
look at our daily lives we need to act
with unity and in a timely manner
mrs van der lion we need genuine unity
and not just a facade of unity
we need to intervene to support
households and companies
that's
essential in taking on the crisis we
have before us
we need clear answers a pr gas price cap
is one of those clear answers
and
uncoupling
the gas
price from the energy price in general
i'll give you a clear example a specific
example
of the kind of speculation we face and
the need to intervene
over the last few days
on the 9th of september
we saw a council of european energy
ministers who sent out a positive and
clear signal but immediately after on
the 12th of september the gas price went
below 200 euros
on the 26th of august it was over 330
euros
but now gas prices are increasing again
because the message that
the markets are getting from the eu is
not strong enough we need a strong
answer now member states need to be
conscious of the difficulties that we
have ahead of us so we need to act in a
timely manner
all of the planning
the cohesion planning for the
2022-2027 period the recovery plan a lot
of this will
depend
on
what happens now because the planning
was done before the outbreak of war
we need to work with conviction towards
ensuring we have genuine unit unity
within the eu i've listened carefully to
declarations from other colleagues
around the plenary the presidents of the
other groups
i understand there's a need for
political polemics to go on because of
national elections that are upcoming in
many countries but that's not the path
we should be following
i'd like to thank the uh support that
we've had for ukrainian refugees the two
ladies who are with us today have set an
excellent example
but
you have to remember that there are
countries like poland who have opened
their arms wide they have shown
exceptional uh
efforts in terms of welcoming refugees
escaping from ukraine
we need to be conscious that unity
it cannot be achieved by seeking
conflict it has to be true and
substantial
the rule of law is important but we
cannot allow the debate on rule of law
to be contaminated by ideological issues
that brings nothing positive
colleagues over the coming months
we'll be working on a lot of issues
together in our common interest we don't
need this kind of political polemics
it shows immaturity and a sense of
irresponsibility we want a serious
europe
that is capable of working together with
national governments that is the path we
should be following
in this context i hope
that we can find a good balanced
approach democracy isn't just for when
it suits you
it doesn't it's not just for when uh
people vote the way you want them to
vote
whether we lose or whether you win an
election you have to represent you have
to respect the citizens mandate to its
politicians that's the only way we can
have a serious incredible europe that
can take on the challenges of the future
thank you
very honorable
now i give the floor to manuel aubry on
behalf of the left group
colleagues
adam zelinska
we've heard a
general
policy speech and the objective must be
to look after the interests and
respond to the concerns of europe's
citizens and
i've come here with the bills
the bills that people
have uh asked me to show you this bill
from
this bill from
gregory to gas bill 2130
euro
people who are worried about uh not
being able to heat their homes
this winter and there are millions of
people like gregoire and uh
the
prices are skyrocketing and it's not
just energy prices
the prices are
rising people's salaries are stagnating
and yet shareholders are cashing in
there are
those
uh who have
plenty
a handful of billionaires
jetting around the planet
and
others
are out on the golf courses
which have to be
uh
watered while
everyone else is in sweltering heat
but there are other people too
and the crisis is not just a result of
the terrible war in ukraine
and putin's blackmail
this crisis has happened because we have
an economic system
that does not work as you have had to
admit today
let's start with taxing mega profits and
for the first time you've accepted that
multinationals are making mega profits
uh please tell bruno le mer
a minister of finance and the economy
who doesn't seem to have noticed
this house
has been asking for the taxation of mega
profits and it's good to see that there
are people listening
and i'm glad that we're winning this
cultural battle
i congratulate your
linguistic creativity
i can imagine you looked in a dictionary
of synonyms
to
avoid the word mega profits
your reference was to
exceptional profits
but this shouldn't just be about fossil
fuels it should be all of the companies
that have
benefited from the crisis be it
uh the shipping sector be the banking
sector be the luxury goods sector
it shouldn't just be energy companies
that are taxed
i see at the end of your term of office
you're
extolling the virtues of the market and
yet we have a
crisis
the
european
union
is having to cross its collective
fingers in the hope that we won't all be
having blackouts this winter that will
have heat and light your model has
failed
now you are
you
your measures are
uh not enough
we have to stop the prices uh rising
it's good that you've
realized
past mistakes but you need consistency
for the future and you didn't say much
about the climate
today
we've had the hottest summer in history
in europe
and
here you go with your free trade
agreements
the planet is burning and yet you want
to import milk from the other side of
the world
through your trade agreements with the
likes of new zealand
i'm afraid
we have to do better in protecting the
natural world
it was the same with the pandemic there
was a quick initial response and then a
quick return to business as usual
and you're talking
about reforming the budget
you talked about uh convention on the
reform of the treaties
but you've ignored the findings of the
conference on the future of europe there
just isn't time to keep kicking the can
down the road
in fact you're
a
prisoner
of a liberal
uh world view which is collapsing around
you
it's a great pity that uh the right of
this house is aligning itself with the
far right
the right has uh chosen its side we are
on the side of solidarity and president
vanderlaan how many more crises is it
going to take before you really learn
the lessons of this failure thomas studs
is dear colleagues
let me just say something to
manon aubry in hungary the socialists
who belong to the smd group the liberal
groups
and the political parties belonging to
the green group
have been in a close political alliance
with the
anti-semitic
political party called jobic
so
if you are against cooperation with the
extreme political forces then
you'd better look
um
at your own courtyard first
madam president
we hungarians
have suffered
german and soviet occupation so we know
all too well what it means to fight um
aggression to fight for independence
as the son of
holocaust survivors i understand the
cruel destruction of war
we all stand
with those under attack
when the sanctions were adopted at the
beginning of the summer the commission
told us that these sanctions would bring
russia to its knees
you promised us that sanctions
will hurt russia not european citizens
you promised us that sanctions
will end the war
the end of the war is nowhere in sight
while energy prices continue to
skyrocket
all this time russia happily pockets
windpole profits
from the energy markets
the sanctions
have brought us galloping inflation
which pushes europeans into poverty
by russia is getting richer
europe faces an energy shortage and
energy crisis madam president
this is not what the commission promised
us
when you introduced the sanctions
the flow back to the president of the
commission usually on the line for five
minutes
thank you
very much and first of all i want to
thank all the presidents of the groups
for
the broad coalition supporting the
proposals of solidarity for the
vulnerable households and companies
and yes
we know time is of the essence
but when i look at madame obrie
the bills you have shown to us
yes in french you would say it's
importable this is right but you know
what send those bills to moscow that's
where they belong to that's where the
sources
[Applause]
i have a plea to this parliament we all
you all rightly so say speed speed speed
time is of the essence you've done
phenomenal things with a digital covet
certificate
please
do that again with repower eu because
you're all rightly so calling for
investment for renewables also
cross-border projects here more than 300
billion euros that are
that could be invested to cross-border
projects you're calling for the
permitting process that it has to be
sped up well the permitting process the
reform is in repower eu you're calling
for stabilizing the ets prices it's in
repower eu and 20 billion fresh money so
please speed up i have the same
call and plea to the european council
and uh the member states please speed up
because we really need you to do again a
miracle like in the covered times
now stephan c journey
you're right we must call out putin's
lies and i want to look at the issue of
food
nothing nothing in our sanctions
prevents russia from exporting food and
fertilizers to vulnerable countries we
have to say that over and over again
because it's the truth and russia just
says the opposite which is a lie
russia has blocked ukrainian harbors a
very simple truth and our solidarity
lanes together with the u.n deal that
was really helpful have now enabled that
more than 10 million tons of grains have
left ukraine
today 30 percent of ukraine's grain
exports are going to low and middle
income countries in africa middle east
and asia so it's ukraine's grain that
has made prices drop again prices for
maize and wheat have decreased by 20
they're almost back to pre-war levels so
we should be very clear in our messaging
fact is
putin has created the food crisis
europe and the united nations are
working to put an end to that that's the
truth
and on
agriculture europe is a top food
agri-food producer and exporter and
that's a great pride
and it gives a special responsibility in
times when so many countries simply
don't have enough food
this is why as you know we have decided
to allow the cultivation of any crops on
set aside land for the next harvesting
season
we know that farmers are also coping
with high prices for energy and for
fertilizers
and therefore less than a month into the
war
we triggered for the very first time the
crisis reserve
under the common agriculture policy
this frees up to 500 million euros for
the most affected farming sectors
and member states can top this up with
another 1.4 billion euros for european
rural development funds
keep in mind
member states can also
use the revenues from the solidarity
contribution we just put on the table as
a proposal
of the oil and gas companies to support
fertilizer production in europe
but finally and again this goes for the
whole energy crisis there's one simple
truth that applies to both energy and
fertilizers the more we save
the less we pay and the less fossil fuel
based fertilizers we use the less
dependent we are on fossil fuel imports
in the last month
globally but also across europe each and
every one of us
felt more clearly than ever before the
immense impact of the global climate
crisis and you've mentioned it all the
heat records the heavy rain events the
floods the devastating droughts
destroying crop and livelihoods
they urge us
to move
more swiftly than ever together
we need a resilient and sustainable
agriculture that preserves biodiversity
and above all the healthy fertile soil
and that can caution all the
aforementioned disasters
therefore
our discussions on chemical pesticides
and mineral fertilizers are crucial
using the natural resources entrusted to
us in a careful and preserving way many
things
thank you very much i give the floor now
on behalf of the council the minister of
european affairs mikolaj peck
thank you very much
president of mitzola
president fonda lyon
honorable members ladies and gentlemen
let me start by thanking you president
fond airline on behalf of the council
for your cooperation and leadership
in these uncertain
and challenging times that europe is
witnessing since russia launched its war
of regression against ukraine and its
people
russia is fighting not only against
ukraine
but also against our values and
principles
for this reason
the czech presidency will never cease to
support ukraine's sovereignty and
territorial integrity using all the
means at the eu's disposal which
includes inter alia providing all the
political military economic and
humanitarian assistance that ukraine may
need
the changes we face are manifold and
their combined impacts are taking a high
toll on our populations
especially the most vulnerable
and on our economies
these challenges also present risks for
our ambitious eu agenda
we need to address the immediate
challenges
while keeping our long-term goal
goals very much in mind it's no easy
task
president fonder lion you have given us
a lot of food for thought
you have addressed the most pressing
issues that require our full collective
attention and the council will no doubt
give its political support to meeting
these objectives
president from the line in number of
your previous speeches you referred to
czech president vladimir
and i thank you for that and indeed as
vaclav havel once said
the tasks ahead of europe deserve
careful and thorough reflection
madam president
you can count on our presidency to help
you rethink rebuild and repower europe
addressing this hemi cycle in july prime
minister fiawa outlined our priorities
which largely align with yours
the most urgent tasks are to address the
various dimensions of the war on ukraine
bring genuine energy security
strengthen europe's defense capabilities
secure the strategic resilience of the
eu economy
and ensure the resilience of our
democratic institutions
energy security and mitigating high
energy prices is our most pressing task
i welcome that the commission is today
following up with its proposals on some
of the measures discussed by the council
last week
we are determined to work around the
clock on these proposals and reach an
agreement among the member states at the
next meeting of energy ministers
scheduled for the 30s of september
however the situation we are facing is
very difficult and complex european
response is necessary
therefore we welcome the commission's
intention to come up with further
measures in the following weeks
all of this we have to keep in mind
while not forgetting
about our long-term goals namely the
green and digital transitions and of
course we will also follow up on the
recommendations of the conference on the
future of europe
the council will do its utmost to
progress at pace on the many initiatives
already on the table
and on the new ones to come
finally we come we welcome the
commission's letter of intent
which the council will discuss next week
together with the annual foresight
report
we look forward to continuing the
dialogue among the three institutions on
our common priorities for the next year
the council will then in november
discuss the new commission work program
with a view to the next joint
declaration on legislative priorities
our joint programming can help us and
our three institutions achieve results
in a focused and targeted way
let me reaffirm the council's commitment
to this process
and assure you that the presidency will
continue to be a determined and sincere
partner thank you for your attention
thank you very much mr beck we go now to
the colleagues starting with secret
murashan for one and a half minutes
thank you president president fondele
and dear colleagues we are all
witnessing this year the people of
ukraine standing up for european values
we admire their resistance their
fighting spirit and we are inspired by
this here in the european parliament and
millions of citizens are inspired across
the european union wanting to live in
freedom in democracy deciding one's own
future this means defending european
values ukraine has has a european path
we here in the european parliament are
convinced of this we have done all we
could for the people of ukraine since
the beginning of the crisis and we will
continue to do so this is why president
van der line long before eu accession
will be possible we should we support
what you have presented today on working
towards bring ukraine closer to the
single market of the european union
because that means freedom of movement
for people for goods for services for
capital it will mean the european union
and ukraine going closer together more
together more possibilities to rebuild
ukraine and to your work to uh to
develop ukraine we shall support this
initiative firstly secondly more
measures and quicker measures to support
citizens in the european union capping
energy prices including prices on
imported russian gas
using existing funds to
for energy interconnectivity for energy
efficiency for reducing dependency and
for investing in renewables this is what
we power eu is about we are finalizing
president dear colleagues work here in
the european parliament to make sure
that money flows where it is needed fast
um but as president from the line you
have announced new measures today we
shall also work together on revising the
budget of the european union we want to
do more we need to make sure that in all
of those areas we have
money to conclude madam president we
also have a duty to make the european
union safer we have enlarged nato
because finland and sweden wanted to
join and because they fulfilled the
criteria we should do the same for the
schengen area for many years romania and
bulgaria are fulfilling the conditions
and croatia now fulfills them as well we
in the parliament have a clear position
the commission has a clear position we
shall be united in pushing the council
to doing this because enlarging schengen
means more security for all of us thank
you very much thank you very much mr
morrison simona bonafena for one minute
grazie president
thank you president
we are facing another serious crisis in
europe one that is
having a huge
effect on our families and companies
that are caught in the grip of rising
electric bills and inflation
like for the pandemic we can't just
stand by watching as families
grow poorer
in the service in the hardest times
europe must act as europe and we must uh
focus on european shared interests
when the pandemic
uh hit the hardest there were those who
uh worked it towards the ideology of
sovereignty and held up our um ideas of
uh solidarity and uh shared um
uh
destiny um what we need to put an end to
uh europe of inertia
uh president vandalia i listen to your
words um on the future that lies ahead
of us on the measures that we need now
to tackle the crisis
a full reform of uh energy markets and
new resources for businesses however we
have to act boldly
uh we can't waste any more time in
putting a cap on gas prices that's the
only thing that put an end to this um uh
dreadful speculation that we're seeing
at the moment europe is will have a
shared destiny or there will be no
europe you were right madame vandalian
our unity is our genuine
uh our true strength and divided we are
condemned to fail thank you fair next is
malik asmani for two minutes
dear president mitzola the miss
president from the lion and the
commissioners and their colleagues i
want to start by praising the people of
ukraine for their enduring bravery a
commitment to freedom
colleagues the progress they have made
shows our aid and assistance to ukraine
is working the eu must supply the
weapons ukraine needs to keep their
momentum
let's communicate directly to the people
of europe about who is responsible for
the cost of live impressions
madam president the origin of high
inflation points to one man
we have a cost of putin crisis
his reckless actions have driven up
every day energy and food costs
for households and businesses in the
short term we must do what is necessary
to limit the economic shock we are
facing
europe's small businesses cannot be left
to pay on sustainable bills for the
maniac in the kremlin
they are the backbone of our economy
madam president so please make sure your
proposals focus on them too
that is why we knew europe had set out a
plan for an energy shield and a food
security strategy and act we must
however
let us be mindful of unintended
consequences
remember that ultimately the market
knows best how to allocate resources
reform the market yes
this figure the market no thank you
madam president
the extreme weather we have seen also
this summer shows the importance of the
green transition
we have to chance to transform our
economy and deliver millions of new jobs
by harnessing new technologies
a temporary energy crisis is no
justification to undermine the green
deal
and finally our migration we need to act
with honduran
not only with arguments about the
advantages of migration
but our citizens expect that we are in
control of migration
and if a package approach doesn't work
then we need to decouple
and start with some important files like
screening at external border has
strengthened also more our efforts on
the external dimension if we do not act
miss vandalian we will see more maloneys
on the european stage
and that is our common responsibility to
prevent thank you thank you mr asmani
and now for one and a half minutes jordi
so there
madam president
confronted with a russian invasion of
ukraine the eu has provided a firm and
united response we rightly decided to
stand with the ukrainian people in the
face of this criminal aggression we did
the right thing
we have to be with those defending
democracy
freedom and ultimately what we like to
call european values
but it should be remember as you did in
your speech
that within our european union these
same values cannot at all times and in
all places be taken for granted either
that here too it is necessary
to defend every day respect for
fundamental rights and democracy
although luckily in our case not with
the force of arms because we do indeed
have problems in this regard and not all
of them are caused by threats coming
from the outside
when in some member states we are spied
on
by the hacking of our phones as has
happened to me
and other colleagues
in this parliament we have a serious
problem
when political and judicial abuses
committed in member states must be
called out by international
organizations as it recently happened to
spain we have a problem
when the rule of law continues to
deteriorate in some member states and we
don't fully use the mechanism to correct
that situation we also have a problem
so madame for thunder lion i can ask you
for more courage to protect to protect
defend and improve the state of
democracy and respect for fundamental
rights in our union thank you thank you
mr soleil
thank you very much madam president
president of the commission well here we
are the people of europe are uh
in trouble
the energy emergency
has been declared the war is part of it
but there's more to the high prices that
we're paying right now
well the road to hell is paved with good
intentions
we have uh dependence on fossil energy
that has placed us in the hands of uh
russia the petro monarchies of the
the gulf and china
this is a
absurd and irrational war
that against nuclear energy that the
greens are leading
we are giving money to the russians as a
result their revenue from oil is
growing exponentially
and we're now trying to replace it with
american shale gas
we're putting us
in the hands of azerbaijan which is now
attacking the population of armenia
well social europe we're now preparing
rationing
for uh europe citizens who are afraid of
the coming winter
you have renounced sovereignty and
plunged our people into distress
facing the kind of emergencies that we
thought we'd put us behind us in history
so
taxing the windfall tax
and uh supporting nuclear these are all
essential measures for trying to get
back to economic normality europe's
peoples are angry
the time will come soon before
you will have to stand before a judge
and say what have you done to the
european dream thank you
for two minutes please
madam president madam president
ladies and gentlemen
we heard something quite important from
president fondo lyon today
she mentioned that it was a mistake not
to have listened to poland and what
poland was saying about eu policy on
russia i'm glad we heard those words
but i wonder
if
this is for real
and we really do want to build a better
european union of solidarity
did we just hear president vanderlian
say that only to go back to business as
usual or is
this really
new way of thinking
we've heard about the need to defend
democracy and the rule of law in various
eu member states
yes
the eu must
defend democracy and the rule of law
but why is it that we hear this
from
the socialist group from the liberal
uh group
why are most of these people french and
why are they only talking about
democracy and the rule of law in hungary
so what kind of democracy are we talking
about is this german democracy
manfred weber is talking about
supporting donald tusk interfering in
the polish elections shouldn't democracy
be about respecting the choices of
voters in other countries what kind of
rule of law are we talking about are we
talking about the kind of rule of law
which respects our treaties and the
constitutions of member states or are we
talking about the kind of rule of law
that suits the germans the french the
rich people with a particular view of
the world
we need
solidarity and unity there is a war
going on
on the other side
of our border we have to unite we have
to build solidarity
to stand up to putin we have to learn
the lessons from the past
there are people in this chamber who've
supported putin who've supported russian
a former chancellor of germany was a
supporter of putin and russian energy
policy that is why
ladies and gentlemen we need to show
more respect for each other and we need
to reflect on what solidarity means
[Applause]
see what found out
madam president
i am very concerned about the times
we're living in in my country sweden we
see a new government being built on with
the support of a right-wing nationalist
and racist party
and at the turn of the year it will be
my country sweden that will be taking on
the eu presidency
it's a shame for the eu's climate policy
to be dependent upon a climate
denialists
the government in
the uh presidency country
is depending on a party that cannot
respond when they're asked whether they
support macron or putin well i may not
be a fan of macron to say the least but
i would always know what size i would
pick
we need to do more to stop the
right-wing extremists in the far right
in europe we need to work on a climate
and
we in the left will call for a policy on
the climate that relies on uh
researchers are not on the climate
denialists we need strong measures
against poland and hungary that are
trampling on the rule of law and
fundamental rights
we need a lively civil society and an
independent judicial system that is not
a luxury that's a basic
women's right to abortion that women
should decide over their own bodies we
will be standing up also for lgbtqi
people's rights
and serbia a candidate country is trying
to ban a pride march that is
unacceptable
russia's war against the ukraine is a
terrible war but it also places demands
upon us of course we need to introduce
in renewable energy to make ourselves
independent from putin but we also need
to reshape the energy markets i welcome
the proposals that you've been made we
need to tax the energy companies much
more strongly than we have done to date
there is no time to lose
not a minute to waste
i hope that you unlike the swedish right
will not be relying on the support of
the far right
because then
we won't be able to stand up for the
climate we won't be able to stand up for
democratic rights we won't be able to
stand up for the welfare state
and we will not
be able to stand up for those we need to
uh bequeath a sustainable europe to
begin for one minute
congrats
thank you president metaller president
colleagues
if we were to think of a symbol of
the eu during the pandemic
it was
uh
the awards full of covert patients but
today it's this this is a electricity
bill that a small businessman has
received for august
um over 5000 years compared with about
uh one and a half last year over triple
the price and because of this a lot of
business people have already had to stop
their work many more will have to do it
and lots of families aren't going to be
able to make ends meet at the end of the
month
and
facing this we can't just have
unproductive summits and and more words
we have to act president van der lion do
you remember the meeting with the
president conte
that is the model that you should take
as your inspiration
the recovery fund is the pole star that
we have to follow during this energy
crisis
now of course other measures are going
to be required um uh shared storage uh
caps on gas prices
but don't take advice from the draghi uh
government because
uh
the work that has been done in italy is
not right we need this money now and
it's our citizens and our businesses
that need this money this francis
fitzgerald for one minute
europe today is facing crisis with war
once again on our continent but europe
has increasingly responded well to
crisis
and our determination to do so again is
unwavering
people and governments are looking to
the eu now more than ever to see how we
can tackle those global problems we know
what they are energy prices climate
change cost of living inflation job
creation announcements are important but
now the eu must act decisively thank you
president for your leadership but we now
need a commitment from all our member
states to implement all of these issues
without delay use the funding as the
president has said that is there i
welcome the supports that have been
announced for families and smes smes are
at the heart of our economies we know
they are the job creators in our member
states only by working together eu and
member states can we ensure that the
worst impacts of putin's winter can be
avoided this should not be about a
battle of competencies but a commitment
to deliver our citizens are waiting
thank you thank you miss fitzgerald
mr alex you saliba for one minute
european citizens are now looking to us
for solutions to the economic and social
crisis we are going through
the action we will take today will
determine the state of the european
union for tomorrow
high energy prices high food prices
galloping inflation negative
consequences
of the coveted 19 pandemic
more unemployment
less spending power for our families
more poverty and greater social
inequality this is only a small part of
a broader problem we are facing a
problem that will
affect many people in the coming years
and that will bring with their dramatic
consequences for the most vulnerable
members of our society
so i believe that we need a european
reinsurance scheme
that will fight against unemployment
that will protect
employment and our workers
we need to protect
people who are living in poverty people
with disabilities our youth
are
elderly people people who are
unemployment employed those who are
working for no salary
platform workers who have no protection
and no rights
thank you mr raju saliba one minute
thank you very much madam president
madam president
well difficult moments in europe indeed
how to continue helping ukraine and at
the same time how to mitigate the energy
crisis in europe
households are struggling to pay the
energy bills
doctors to close their
practices
industries preparing massive
redundancies
there is a french
german spanish way how to deal with this
crisis
it's time to decide
what we must do at european level
to help citizens in their current
struggle and those industries heavily
affected
some companies will receive state aid in
one country while the same sector in
another country will not
we need to ensure a fair level playing
field for all affected sectors in europe
winter is coming we need solidarity
common rules
targeted help for affected businesses
and above all for our citizens thank you
very much thank you very much mr
ransomware montenegro
president
thank you for your speech
and thank you
uh for the um
homage you paid to
the greens and
environmentalists referring to the
actions of the 1970s
um
madame president
uh in the efforts that we're going to
have to make for the green transition
that we want to see we need to have the
financial means for that and there's a
fundamental political question here
when you want to finance change you have
to ask your question who is going to pay
now you have
um
put forward an exceptional tax on super
profits but
we need to look at uh profits in general
and uh financial transactions and so
forth you know that for the recovery
plan and perhaps future recovery plans
we have been discussing a fair taxation
and to do that we need your support to
ensure that member states will work
together
also you said that we were visionaries
uh 40 years ago and now we are asking
you uh to understand that hydrogen is
not the
magic recipe to uh solve all of our
problems we want to focus on um
developing renewable energies in a
decentralized manner thank you very much
next is gunabek for one and a half
minutes
thank you president uh commission
president
we expected a speech on the state of the
union and got one on ukraine the
blessings of public debt
the green religion and the fantasy
economy
tactically
what we see in fact is in the eu we've
got stagflation
nine percent inflation and the lowest
growth in the developed world
for germany the ifo institute is
forecasting a recession and an inflation
rate of over 10 percent
at the same time in switzerland
they have 3.5 percent inflation and 2.6
percent real growth
well that shows that hyper inflation is
avoidable and solid growth in europe is
still possible
our stagflation is not a consequence of
covid or the war in ukraine but rather
it's homemade through badly thought
through sanctions in the green deal that
has made energy un unaffordable and has
zero influence on the world climate
so now the eu migration pact is going to
pull thousands of millions of migrants
to us
now every individual migrant costs us
according to a danish study more than
600 000 euros
well the ecb is just going to print more
money for that the increase in the
monetary mass and the fall in the euros
value are just going to lead to more
inflation
well if anyone asks me what we should do
i always say it's simple just do the
absolute opposite of what german
governments and the eu commission have
been doing for years now that would be
the cheapest recovery plan and the only
possible future for next generation eu
thank you mr beck next is robert zealer
vice president for your flow the floor
is just one and a half minutes
brexit
madam president uh madame van der lyon
to start with i must say that this was
the best of the state of the union
speech that i've heard here during the
numerous years i've been in this house
but only in that part which gives the
quick
actions that we have to take and you
said that in this complicated situation
uh we have to do certain things and i
think that in this part you tried not to
please too much various political forces
in this house this is a year of
awakening when most of europe
was in deep sleep with eyes wide shut
we have to open the eyes and have to
understand that the situation has
changed and we have to strengthen our
threshold of pain a few years ago we uh
made uh energy union but instead of that
it resulted in new pipeline to russia
and it hurts many i would like to say
that your program in the in respect of
energy market is acceptable and i urge
you to take fast steps and to negotiate
to talk with the member states and
ensure that this doesn't destroy the
single
energy market that we have
before the war in ukraine we started
building the strategic compass but the
war in ukraine and the ukrainian
reliance mainly on on our transatlantic
partners and its european neighbors i
think in my opinion it makes us rethink
the direction of this compass and also
the expansion of nato shows where this
uh
security needle of the compass points to
that's why i urge you to focus on the
most important and the crucially
decisive things and don't waste uh let's
not waste our time on unimportant stuff
um dear roberts can i ask you to to
pause do i see that miss graffini has a
blue card for you
scrapping it will you take it
okay scrubbing you have the floor
roberts you can come back to the lectern
to answer
thank you
i will need to get you yeah there it is
um
you said that
the state of the union address is an
important moment in time before this
parliament
and has been marked by the desire of the
president that's true
we're talking about 25 million people
living on a minimum wage
as we look forward to 20 30 20 35 how
can we project ourselves forward without
forgetting reality given the rhythm with
which dozens are taken and then put into
practice they're taking considerable
period of time
uh we're entering into the winter period
um
what can be done in concrete terms for
our citizens mission so please can that
be fixed while uh i think uh i'll catch
the point in english so uh well um
of course there are difficult and it's
very painful time but uh while my group
and also my political views is always
that everybody all ruling us
like governments and parliament level
should do their own work on this crisis
situation for example i i think this is
mostly should be done to decrease this
pain level by national government and at
the same time european union levels
should take responsibilities to keep its
inner balance in the joint actions in a
single market an energy problem system
that's good that's my ideal combination
how we can solve this crisis thank you
thank you very much uh vice president
next is leftedes nicolas for one minute
the speech of our presidents was a
military delirium european monopolies
are using in many ways this
imperialistic war sanctioned against
russia and now they're putting
themselves in position to reconstruct
and quotation mark the ukraine our
people should not have to take sides in
this imperialistic war in this
competition between the u.s nato eu with
russia and china and this pretend
european solution is a blackmail to the
people pay or freeze but you know
inflation started a lot before the war
because of your green transition because
of the deregulation of energy a
delineatization the
companies that are all the more uh
profitable and
you know you can't say that the energy
multinationals are going to share their
profits with people this is um
capitalist um exploitation and
uh
these crisis are all uh getting worse um
refugees wars so what we need is this
energy which is going to be a social
good not something to be traded and it's
owned by the people and of course
leaving the eu
president van der lion
president you know the parliament uh
president vandal fondo line
first of all i would like to express our
solidarity to ukraine and i would like
to very much welcome your initiative
to invite the first lady from ukraine to
come along to the session today to
express our solidarity with ukraine and
the ukrainian people and i would like to
thank very much the commitment that you
have made
for this work on behalf of the epp
because obviously
in order to be prepared for the
challenges of the future we need this
kind of support from you now
during the course of your
speech on the state of the union this
morning at on a number of occasions
you've made
reference to the errors we've made in
the past which have led to this
dependence on russia and you said that
the member states and the european union
didn't necessarily hear or listen to
properly certain
uh heads of state and governments from
certain member states if you take a look
at the international pipe from between
the iberon peninsula and france
president macron is refusing that
interconnector is the european
commission going to be complicit in this
once again the prime minister antonio
costa has met
president macron but he's not managed to
persuade him to accept this
interconnector pipe
and we're seeing that france is refusing
progress so are we going to make the
same mistake repeat the mistake we made
with nordstrom 2 and have that kind of
energy dependency we've got excellent
solutions elsewhere as well in greece
and italy but the iberian peninsula
could provide this response to the
energy situation so how's the european
commission going to reply to mr macron
president
yes thank you very much president
president of the commission dear
colleagues
over the past few months and in the face
of the invasion of ukraine our citizens
have
responded on the basis of solidarity
today
we can
get a greater feeling of this war in
europe and we have to make sure that the
solidarity shown by us citizens towards
ukraine does not lose in strength
uh president von uh the lion
we've been talking you refer to social
protection yes we do have to make
progress there progress has been made in
portugal and spain and in the case of
energy we see that some of the prizes
have been been brought down so that is a
partial response
we can see that the commission is trying
to make progress but the council is
dragging its feet at the same time we've
seen that energy bills are really making
families suffer and industry and
business as well we need to be protected
from the effects of unemployment and we
want to a future
without populism and we really have to
act now so that the winter does not
freeze the hopes and expectations of our
europeans for one minute
president the state of the union
couldn't be more tense putin's waging a
war and an energy war against europe as
a whole and we need to be sort of clever
and united otherwise i think we're going
to slide into a winter of rage all
sources of energy
are important when it comes to avoiding
sort of social disruption we need all
available
energy sources sidestepping nuclear is
wrong and unrealistic energy is going to
be clean but affordable throughout
society
in order to counter market disruptions
in the crisis that's true but madame van
der lyon we're not going to get a cat
blanche in order to intervene in the
single market uh endlessly that wouldn't
be an emergency economy but a planned
economy
we need a
a cap on electricity for a limited
period of time we need network
infrastructure and we need to open up
strategic energy sources such as fusion
um but you europe needs a very different
kind of energy energy for reform or a
form of fiscal rules tighter fiscal
rules without adding to the debt
mountain we need reform for the eu and
that is a promise that you made
madam president of the commission it's
for you now to act on that present
promise we are expecting concrete steps
towards a convention in order to make
europe fit and not only for the coming
winter and next is heidi hart allah for
one minute
dear president fonder lion
you mentioned that through trade policy
we can not only strengthen our economy
but also promote shared values with
like-minded countries
and one year ago you made the important
announcement the eu will put in place a
ban on imports of goods made with forced
labor
and i understand that the commission is
now expected to publish its proposal for
such a law in a couple of hours could
you confirm this
there are 50 million modern slaves in
the world today and the majority of them
work in the global value chains with
often a european consumer at the end of
the chain
we must do everything to ensure that eu
or its companies are not complicit in
supporting state-sponsored or other
forced labor
and
it's very important that when violations
do happen effective remedy to victims
needs to take place dear president
finally
the report finally released by the u.n
high commissioner for human rights
missile basiler is yet another proof of
horrendous abuses including massive
forced labor amounting to at the very
least crimes against humanity in
xinjiang will you make sure that the eu
enforces an effective regime alongside
the u.s and other global partners
before even the conclusion of further
trade agreements thank you
i give the floor next to gerald for
anamans for one and a half minutes
thank you madam president
recorded last year
in the station
i've been hearing in recent days and
months that more or more people seem to
be placing i hopes in the european union
i'm not sure if this works in english
but in dutch we have an expression for
this
it's like going to confess to the devil
in our language what we mean by this
is that victims throw themselves into
the arms of those who cause their
problems
since the financial crisis the european
union has almost doubled money supply
which directly led to this explosion of
inflation
for years now we've been talking about
the green deal closing down nuclear
power stations cutting off energy
supplies this has led directly to the
explosion of energy crisis which was
already underway well before the russian
invasion of ukraine
and with its so-called reset concepts
sustained development and building back
better rubbish the european union
has further promoted the
de-industrialization of our continents
and the collapse of small and
medium-sized businesses and farmers
at the same time we've been forcing
through more and more immigration
and destroy elements of our culture such
as the social system
this means
people must finally wake up the european
union is not the solution it's actually
the biggest cause of the problems
thank you madam president
thomas vondelayen ministers colleagues
commission
we're talking today about the state of
the union the european union and
obviously the current status crisis
an energy crisis
for many years now the european
commission and the parliament
have been sabotaging nuclear power and
making it possible for us to produce
their own fossil fuels
we now have to we're expected to rely on
unreliable wind and sun solar craft
winter's coming and we're blaming russia
but there's been a total lack of careful
thought about this
our voters are suffering from
an income crisis
inflation uh is now in double figures
which means that
savers money is going up in smoke
there's no solution to this from the
european union
all of this is part of a much larger
crisis which is a crisis of national
sovereignty
with practically all the problems which
the european union is currently
wrestling with they're all caused by the
federalist ideology of the european
commission
european union has become an aim per se
everything should be green
and the citizens are simply an obstacle
in the road for the european commission
we talked about trade we have to find
our own solutions what works for
netherlands doesn't necessarily work for
portugal and vice versa but that's no
longer possible to recognize that in the
european union the european union is
drawing more and more powers to itself
euro federalism
has been leading us from one crisis to
another
we can no longer carry on like this we
really have to come to a time where we
might have to move back to europe
comprised of sovereign nations
thank you president president you said
it was a battle between autocracy and
democracy yes well that's how we would
describe the combat
you recall the words of president sasoli
who said that democracy has to be
updated
and here we're talking about a crime a
war outside but unfortunately you didn't
mention the very serious threats from
inside the european union
you didn't remind or recall that a
democracy
obviously has to
apply to citizens politicians
journalists etc where it's being it's
under threat as is the case in spain and
greece and democracy has to respect the
rulings of the court so which is not the
case in spain
where 61
of court rulings are not being respected
democracy we need a democracy to fight
autocracy but we have to do this from
the inside as well and this is not
really all that clear especially
when we see that some of your
commissioners have photographs taken
together with members of the extreme
right and then we see politicians being
spied on minute to daniel caspari
for client
smes um an offensive external trade um
strategy in securing uh sources of raw
materials thank you madam president for
your concrete proposals that are
encouraging but i think as parliament
what we need to do
is uh send a
message that we're tackling burdens on
society uh the zero pollution package
the um
uh various health plans the supply chain
legislation and and and
ladies and gentlemen uh citizens are
already facing major challenges they
need more room uh
more breathing space we have got to
guard against further
strains on the society please take these
issues seriously we are doing what we
can to
um to avoid them life is becoming more
and more expensive we're talking about
uh protection measures uh three million
hectares uh sort of the various million
tons of the
serial less will be produced in the
future that will exacerbate the position
i wonder whether you might not want to
reflect on withdrawing that proposal in
this difficult time we want more as sort
of a local agriculture more crops being
produced and not the country
thankfully
yes thank you president
president of the commission
crisis climate pandemic the russian war
in ukraine
and now an energy crisis as well so
crises which require
common shared solutions that political
courage and real leadership and i'm
expecting that the commission will be
able to assume all of these challenges
support and solidarity for ukraine this
has to be continued and it's important
that women and children
that we pay special attention to them
and we need
we've welcomed this good news on
rebuilding schools in ukraine but
looking ahead to the winter we also need
some kind of measures in order to bring
down the
extremely high energy prices in the
european union the member states
but this doesn't mean that we should
stop our efforts when it comes to the
climate transition
and more than ever i think at this
moment the european union has to act as
a guarantor for democracy and stability
in these difficult times this giver
hofstra for one minute
thank you madam president it's a real
shame that mr bazelo is nowhere
he really
has a cheek
to have said what he said this morning
to attack the president of the
commission saying that she's to blame
for inflation
price increases everybody knows it's the
war in ukraine
launched by putin
and him and his friends have spent years
supporting and sympathizing with putin
he really has got a cheek
and maybe somebody's paying him
i don't know what's on the americans
list i wouldn't be surprised
if miss
miss le pen's name and other members of
the rasam renational were to figure on
that list because of payments from
russia but then i i thought there was
one black hole in your uh uh
not so big as those were discovered for
the moment but
uh that is the uh the absence of defense
because i think really that we're going
to live in a total new world order
with huge problems
for our security and you never know what
happens if tweeting trump is returning
in the u.s
then we will be on our own for our own
security so a defense community is an
absolute necessity we are spending today
240 billion euro on defense in europe
the same amount as china
four times more as russia
we have 130 weapon systems in europe we
have a world record of soldiers in the
world 2.4 million and we are powerless
that's at least the sentiment of most
people
so my request to you is when we have a
convention and thank you for supporting
it so clearly we need to talk also by
that and you need to come forward
which i shouldn't say a copy but a draft
like the treaty of paris of 1952
negotiated by adenauer
de gaspari
and robert schumann
that's the way forward don't forget it
and fill the black hole please thank you
very much mr hobstart next is
jacques madison for one minute
[Applause]
thanks so much madam president uh
dear keith hofstadt
i would start with the ghee when he
mentioned that the real reason for the
huge prices is putin
i have chosen to correct you
the prices started increased six months
before the war
we had problems already in last year in
december and january and putin was just
a trigger for the real reason and the
real reason is that we have had a crazy
green
policy in last two decades
we are hating the fossil fuels we are
hitting the nuclear like in germany it's
a perfect idea of course shut down the
nuclear it's really bad it's risky
let's let's let's let's hope for the
unstable wind and sun it's amazing idea
go to sweden in january there's a lot of
sun it's beautiful it's like in spain in
the summer absolutely it's a stable
energy
and this is the reason why we gave the
power to putin to play with us and this
is also the fault of mrs van der leyen
what did the european commission a time
when germany started to build nordstrom
2 nothing they said oh it's not a
political thing it's just an economical
thing
there is no
economics without politics and that's
also your fault you're also responsible
and lasting decades when you didn't
invest anything in the german defense
and now you're surprised oh we can't
help ukraine anymore thank you for being
with us
thank you mr madison we'll give you the
throw now
thank you thank you mr madison we give
the floor now to martin sonnebond for
one minute
dear
madame vanderline uh to use the word of
carlikaus
uh nothing comes to mind when talking
about the state of the union
if you look at gas uh the gas supply uh
waging a brutal war putin he's
attempting to wage um
uh war of aggression a number of media
asylum over the situation of the sort of
oil uh dick uh dictatorship and then we
see what's happening in democratic
armenia
um but then we have to rely on
azerbaijan when it comes to upholding uh
oppressor freedoms although they're way
behind russia in that respect
and then
alif seems to be standing way out in
front
we've learned in the meantime that um
we're sort of neutral in terms of uh
morality we have refugees queuing up to
join us
and uh we're sort of deleting sms's
paying out millions to pfizer nothing
really comes to mind when talking about
the state of the union
uh we shouldn't really leave europe to
the amateurs
for one minute
for our parliament's president
thank you madam president so madam
president of the commission council
ladies and gentlemen
ukraine
still needs as much support as we can
possibly provide
madam president you said it's time to
support not for appeasement i can only
support that
however
our citizens our businesses are also
being hearted by this crisis very high
inflation horrific energy prices
households have got no room for maneuver
businesses are cutting production and
bankruptcy is looming on the horizon
so we talked about first of all the
light supply problems
that we have to focus on resources and
capacity that applies to energy
resources as well as food resources
secondly
we have to reduce the burden for our
citizens rather than increasing it
that's the overall message i've heard
that we're talking about an sme package
so i think that's a fantastic idea i'm
not sure if i should believe it
i know that the
machinery in the commission is
continuing to work as ever as business
as usual
so i very much welcome the proposals
regarding what knew we need to do
what we have to try to do is maintain
production and value in europe so as to
avoid other regions
benefiting from this war in europe thank
you to gabby bishop for one minute
[Applause]
dear colleagues
the
ghost of recession is wafting through
the european union and we have to do
something about this but we have to take
a look at the
a competition of deeds rather than nice
words
now president you've uh referred to
specific projects price caps etc certain
fiscal measures
which is all good but there's something
that we've systematically ignored and
that is the dreadful consequences of the
war and how to deal with those because
we have seen that there is a fear to
slide into poverty
and a fear of not being able to pay
bills
and
anxious anxiety in the
sme world as well it would be negligent
of us if at this particular moment in
time we didn't have a sure
2.0 or sure plus so that we are well
armed and well prepared and don't end up
facing mass unemployment as well and
this is why i have a request we have to
have
social re-armament as it were because
social peace in europe needs this adrian
busquez lazara for one minute
[Music]
thank you madam president
this is not just another state of the
union debate the measures you've
announced to date and the way in which
we can implement them
will have a major impact in shaping the
future of our common project
and more than ever we require courage
solidarity and resistance
so congratulations to the
daring proposals you've made i hope that
we will succeed in implementing
and i hope that we will be succeed in
lessening the impact of threats facing
our citizens over the next winter
however don't forget this winter won't
just last four or five months would last
much longer this is why we need medium
and long-term solutions
such as the construction of
infrastructure interconnection
infrastructure improving links for
energy so as to enable us to move
towards the energy independence which we
need so badly
can we continue to support a moratorium
in nuclear power
enabling us to move towards green
objectives
while at the same time asking for
further sacrifices from our citizens
we've asked them enough already
and we've been asking this for years now
and they simply can't wait any longer
says harald willinski for one minute
you for president
thank you president ladies and gentlemen
it's good that we're talking about the
state of europe today
uh because it's um
things are
so bad uh the situation hasn't been as
bad for a long time
um
jealous
might suggest things will only get
better but i think we've learned um
that
politics are going the wrong way
the
the european nomenclature would drive
europe into the uh wall that would
certainly be the case uh today just two
examples of that firstly the corona
uh madness
where
we had a continent-wide lockdown
uh lockdown policies undermining the
welfare state we've uh manufactured
unemployment with the firm's uh
businesses going to the wall and then
there's the sanction madness in terms of
the war russia's waging against ukraine
where we're not uh sort of standing out
for peace but we're sending money and
weapons and placing european
uh citizens in an emergency situation
we're saying don't take you know baths
have showers uh turn the heating down um
and i hope that with the forthcoming
elections things will change so that
you'll be able to move the direction of
peace and prosperity for as many
european citizens as possible thank you
milan urich for one minute
okay
yes thank you very
much the lion you said that you need to
fight against corruption corruption
within the eu
so
why don't you want to publish your
communication with the director with the
ceo of pfizer here we're talking about
the
sale purchase rather of fuzzy vaccines
worth 30 million euros you're keeping
the secrets from the public from the
auditors this is the real image of the
eu you think this is transparent
on the basis of this you want european
citizens to trust the eu
you said that uh europe
gave
uh europe ukraine uh i know how many
billion euros and again let me ask you
uh
where does this money come from and what
is not being paid instead uh who do we
pay this money uh to isn't this being
stolen by oligarchs uh is somebody
controlling where all these billions and
billions of uh euros from uh european
taxpayers
where all this money goes or is this
also toxic question a toxic question now
because somebody might find it uh not so
pleasant
to hear i really don't want this eu to
serve only corporations and superpowers
we'll to be talking about this again and
again because this is our work thank you
for one minute
president president of the commission
yes there is war in europe
and not only the crimes and aggression
in ukraine the russian aggression but
also
a war about energy security of supply
war
labor
but we're also fighting over citizens
rights as well
and everybody anybody that attacks the
solidarity and the unity of our european
union and community
and tries to undermine our efforts to
defend those most important ideas
is they're standing together with russia
or the enemies of europe and their
allies of putin
and this is why i would very much like
to thank you
that your warm words about poland and
the reservations and
i think what we have to do is
ensure that we do strengthen the
european energy union going back towards
of donald donald tusk but i think we
also ought to spread ourselves and take
a look at ukraine moldova georgia some
of the balkan countries because and try
and bring them into the uh our community
as well so we have to show
in practice our european solidarity and
to the czech presidency
uh
obviously we took a first step in 2007
with some of the steps we take then but
we need
signatures as well we need
to get cross-party cross-group
support and signatures from id to go to
the greens as well so that all
families everybody from the central
administrations
because we have to try and persuade
russian society over to what's being
done is wrong because
we have to show out send out this
message i think one minute
we very much commend the proposals
you've made
however we believe the time has come for
us to act together
and uh
as quickly as possible the messages
you've announced and that's the term of
energy for example are something which
we as socialists have been calling war
for many months now
madame president you can't ask people to
consume less energy
while at the same time
enabling markets such as eds to continue
if we want to cut energy bills
we have to bring an end to speculation
on spot markets for example the european
union schengen
as you know schengen is not complete you
said beforehand that romania has
fulfilled all the criteria to join the
schengen area
you i know you hope that bulgaria and
romania will be able to join soon i can
promise you that my country has been
working every day to fulfill the
criteria so as to protect the eastern
borders of the european union so madam
president i do hope that your
declarations will be translated into
reality so that to ensure that romania
bulgaria and croatia can join the
schengen area thank you
thank you dear president in the last two
years europe has gone through several
crises that it managed to partially or
fully solve
the food crisis however due to its
nature is much more difficult to tackle
its effects are particularly devastating
for the poorest and most vulnerable
people and even for our cohesion
we are dealing with a complex subject
with impacts on consumers on farmers but
also on transporters on industries on
trade but also has a geopolitical and
strategic impact
the warning signs are already there
we see soaring food energy and
fertilizer prices and we cannot afford
to wait any longer to take action let's
not ignore the consequences and have a
coherent plan that together with my
colleagues having experience in
agri-food
policy we started to working on it but
we need your support uh mr mrs president
the human tragedy for the war in ukraine
must not be combined with another
looming tragedy a global food crisis
because when we are already in a food
crisis it's too late to act it's too
costly uh to act so that's why we have
to prevent this
and if we do not act now the cost of
social economic and even security and
geopolitical terms
will become too high so we call on you
mrs president to come up with a
comprehensive agenda for global food and
nutrition security and we will be here
to help i heard today some ideas some
proposals the commission already took
some measures but what we need is more
than just supporting farmers we need
supporting farmers but we need more for
that because food security uh
means more than just producing thank you
food
thank you mr cholosh next is your
knowledge book done
[Applause]
ladies and gentlemen i stand before you
as a representative of one of the
countries that is most attached to the
values of the european family
solidarity uh through a feeling of
solidarity in europe romania came to the
assistance of ukrainians who are fleeing
war in the name of solidarity
[Music]
we have a sister the passage of trains
uh full of cereals uh heading for
western europe and uh in the other
direction there are trains a convoy is
taking assistance and aid to ukraine in
the
name of solidarity
romania agrees with providing energy to
those who have less in the name of
solidarity but
in terms of its own legislation
romania
welcomes entry into the shanking area
after a long and unjustified wait of 11
years there are a number of countries
knocking on the door romania has
fulfilled all the conditions and secured
its borders using its own resources
where is solidarity
i think there is a risk if we see the
number of uh populist nationalists on
the increase is that anyone who's going
to
bear that
risk when we have a majority of people
who are eurosceptics rather than
pro-european
the european
people are not asking for favors but
dignified status in europe based on uh
solidarity and continuity we want
justice for romania we want to be part
of the schengen area that is our right
thank you very much madam president
nobody can imagine the morality and
power strength of somebody who defends
his own such as the ukrainians we have
felt the war ourselves and know this
best our citizens
show solidarity with the ukrainians but
we need to ensure that this crisis does
not come at the cost of the citizens we
need to ensure a permanent european
crisis mechanism to some this is a gift
a system where small entrepreneurs pay a
larger percentage of tax than a large
multinational company is deeply unjust
we need european taxes but also an
efficient global response let us take
from those who have and give to those
who are in need
croatia is facing a special challenge
prices are on the rampage and some are
using the introduction of euro to profit
from it as well i salute intentions to
prevent corruption european legislation
is the only hope for some unfortunately
but we need to fight on all levels
against those who put their own
profit in front before the interest of
the citizens thank you shook for one
minute
thank you very much president miss van
der laan thank you very much for all
your efforts i do believe that europe
should be united not only internally we
should not allow any division because
third factors outside expect that but
also outside of europe we should be
united we should have the authority to
build new partnerships and to stand
behind our values we're talking about a
political community i do like this idea
very much i think we should have new
partnerships and new friendships but
it's very difficult to
to see the western balkans as this part
of community and they do have to be part
of the european union historically and
geographically they are part of europe
and i do want them to be an integral
part of the european union
generations on end many national
politicians have been working to come
close to europe the first challenge that
we have is
to make um europe different in 2024
because then the populace against
liberal democrats will fight an even
bigger battle and i think we need the
right answers here and i do believe that
the conference on the future of europe
has a lot of answers to give the
conclusions were very good and i do
believe that these conclusions
should be implemented in practice and
there should be a real convent where a
convention where all the
answers will be given
[Applause]
yes thank you very much president only a
few days ago
putin
buried without honor mikhail gorbachev
how wrong they are in kremlin because
history will remember
michelle gorbachev and condemn putin and
the
resistance the
heroism of ukraine the best way in
resisting what's going on there and
obviously europe is going to stand firm
as a rock in support of ukraine because
ukraine the cause of ukraine is uh
one of europe
obviously there are very many challenges
in the wake of this we have to fight
ceaselessly against inflation because
this is totally unfair for our families
we have to strengthen our energy
community and sector so that the it's
not the citizens that pay for the
increase in prices we also have to do
something about defensive uh
freedoms and rights in latin america and
uh support having countries but i think
there is
a source of energy which is much more
powerful than oil and gas and that is
our european values democracy our
freedoms and our rule of law
as
somebody
as a spanish poet said these are arms
that are
armed for the future thank you and uh
long liver free ukraine
madam president madam president of the
commission
i think much of what you said today
should and must be supported
however the key issue
is that we ensure that we don't
underestimate the enormous potential
social impact of this crisis
our citizens can no longer afford the
cost of living they're being hit by
inflation riding food and other prices
underlined by the enormous jump in
energy prices
it's important for us to tax xf profits
we have to try to use that money to help
those who can no longer afford to feed
their homes
however
the way that energy markets have been
designed
they no longer work we need a radical
intervention
the liberalization of energy markets has
been a failure
at the end of the day
this process is nothing neither
guaranteed supply or reasonable prices
moreover we have to learn lessons from
this is why we shouldn't go too far with
liberalization in many other areas i
know there's a tendency for the
commission to push forward with such
ideas in particular the rail sector
this is why ladies and gentlemen i
believe that
the overriding priority for us must be
to remember the social impact of what's
happening so as to ensure that we don't
further tear apart our society thank you
bellamy for one minute
madam president the crisis that we're
traversing is forcing us all
uh to look reality in the face in
particular when it comes to energy so
you can emerge from our independence
and protect the environment you want to
develop wind energy you quoted
denmark as an energy with 10 000 uh
wind farms it depends on the coal mines
and has to
import electricity and sweden's as a
carbon imprint of 50 less if we um
allow germany to close its nuclear power
plants but have to export
gas we're going to have to
import gas from azerbaijan depend on
another criminal regime i hope that
we will
all stand up to counter alif's
aggression against armenia
looking at reality means refusing rules
where we see a drop in agricultural
production in europe whereas uh the
increase in food prices we're seeing
throughout we should
not increase
outdated
trade treaties we want to guard against
future vulnerability we want to
support frontex
patrol our borders rather than
undermining it what we need to do is
better train and educate young people
you talk about solidarity between
generations uh
writing that into the treaties we share
the spirit of that but
that starts with a reality check just
for one minute
thank you president
and commit president of the commission
thank you for your brilliant
presentation of the state of the union
i think however
we should really be talking about the
positive evolution the positive trends
of the
state of the union and this is because
there has been a change of paradigm
obviously we there's a possibility of
social division austerity that would be
one response but we've decided to opt
for unity solidarity and protecting the
interests of the majority against the
interests of a few and we've placed
citizens right at the heart of our
political actions there are two urgent
tasks that we have to face
we have to make sure there aren't any
power cuts in across europe for homes
and industry and then of course we do
have to help the
neediest in our societies and this is
why this
these socialists very much support the
measures that you've put forward in your
uh speech and these are measures that
have been being applied by the spanish
government for over a year
and i'm very happy to see that they have
found their way up to the european level
what is um lamentable however is that
the right wing in my country is refusing
them one by one to try and undermine us
i've been sick for one minute
[Applause]
for president
madam president madam president of the
commission
colleagues
the european economy is going through a
very gloomy period
more and more
taxes are undermining our
competitiveness as is the case with the
pushing through the green deal and
sanctions against russia this lack of
accompanying measures for our companies
one german company in five
is thinking about transferring
production abroad and following comments
from the german economics minister
suggesting that some bakers could close
down temporarily because of high energy
costs and the bakers can then buy a
consumers can buy bread from low-cost
retail outlets
that's not something which encourages
optimism that's very bad of course for
the european economy but for the german
confidence of the european economy
this is why it's so important that we
succeed at the european level in quickly
bringing energy costs under control this
is important for our companies our
citizens jobs and competitiveness the
european union has to demonstrate
that
it's not going to by brandish by flexing
our political muscles we don't want to
force our economy into bankruptcy
president vanderlian we represent hope
when we don't close our eyes to those
who are in need when we don't direct
wars along our borders when we combat
forms of injustice these words of david
uh
we need to remember them today they're a
sort of a warning for us all europe as
you have quite rightly underscored has
to start a convention in order to reform
itself uh to do away with the veto
rights and uh finally have the powers
that we need and protect citizens
against war inflation um
to protect our citizens against rising
energy prices we have the nationalist
rights standing the way that in the
poland and the ultra nationalists in
holland and the package of the joints
the democracy that you announced today
is very important i hope the lager will
vote in favor
um it's um
the only party that would uh disagree
with that but unfortunately uh
george maloney fratelli d'italia is
flirting with trump uh hoping a repeat
of brexit and once again that runs
counter to our interest the interests of
italians and europeans but nationalism
has already lost out on this continent
in spite of the shameful uh complicity
of their so-called moderates uh we need
to put an end to their dealings i'm sure
next is andre kovacier for one minute
thank you madam president
i do welcome the clear willingness of
the european commission to continue its
support for ukraine and to show
solidarity with the ukrainian people
who fight against the russian aggression
the bulgarian motto
united we stand strong must guide the
european council too the more united we
are
the more
quickly we will overcome our challenges
be they energy prices or anything else
the the concealed president of the
council we have another armored conflict
on the sovereign territory of armenia i
urge you very much that european union
is doing the utmost to stop this killing
of people in the last two days tens if
not hundreds of people are killed civil
infrastructure is destroyed this must
stop i don't believe that the russians
are interested for long
standing uh peaceful solution they like
to stay there and to have their
influence there but not to have a peace
in the caucas region so this is up to us
the european union to take the role of a
mediator to stop this conflict thank you
very much thank you andre next is
jensgaya for one minute
thank you
thank you president mrs vondeline i'd
like to thank you for the proposals that
you have made in the face of the energy
price price energy price and
tax on windfall product profits that's a
good thing
and also in order to separate
electricity gas prices and i think
that's an excellent idea
who knows maybe we may come up with an
idea which will work better in times of
peace but the most important thing is
the gas price
we know what's wrong with all of this
and we know that
we need new proposals and i hope very
much that we will make swift progress on
these proposals mrs fonda line when you
talk about the state of union
obviously we're talking about the state
of democracy and the rule of law in the
european union you can't be silent on
that
that was a bit of a gap in your speech
but it doesn't mean that that should
disappear from our agenda and it's only
by overcoming these that we can really
guarantee the state of our union
thank you madam president of the
commission and thank you for giving us
an opportunity to speak you spoke a lot
about energy and rightly so and to your
credit
you've gone down the world trying to get
energy supplies for europe
but i'm sorry to say that in my country
we have an opportunity to build an lng
terminal
free of charge to the government which
one arm of government is blocking
we also have vast gas resources of our
coast
which are not being utilized
and yet we are largely dependent on one
pipeline from the united kingdom
and today the united kingdom said
if russia cuts off supplies of gas to
europe then there will be gas rationing
and electricity outages in the united
kingdom and ireland
so i would ask you
to ask countries like ireland to use the
resources and opportunities they have
and actually be scrounging on the
supplies that other member states need
and also to remove
the
roadblocks to the deployment of
renewables especially planning and
permission i won't finally ask maybe not
to put the clocks back this winter to
save energy
thank you sean next is crystal chaldea
for one minute
thank you very much
the greatest test for community is how
do you handle the crisis you meet
together
and if putin thought that invading
ukraine would divide us in the eu he was
very wrong
because he has shown that european
values
when they are attacked we stand together
just like we did with covet but now it's
the energy crisis and inflation that is
threatening us
businesses are threatened citizens are
threatened we need to solve that but the
crisis is not just a financial threat
it's also a threat to our future
people talk about reducing our green
ambitions proposed postponing green
initiatives but that's not the right way
to go so my message is quite simple
the inflation and energy crisis mustn't
stop our green transition it has to be a
stepping stone let's not slow down but
increase in the green transition
because the eu has shown that we can
stand together when it really matters
also when it comes to the climate crisis
thank you
very much
madam president of the parliament
president of the commission
thank you thank you for your inspiring
statement i think it should be a source
of inspiration for us all and thank you
for recording the force or the strength
of the unions the fact that we can act
together if we're united and thank you
also for once again having expressed
your solidarity with the ukrainian
people uh what is happening in ukraine
is um concerns our future the future of
our children so thank you for having
said that so forcefully
you've also put forward some very
tangible short-term measures in the
field of energy in the energy sector
and
you know how in our countries so many
families are despairing very many
businesses undertakings are experiencing
difficulties and you
have the courage to suggest that the
major energy firms contribute they have
after all benefited
from
sort of a huge they're huge um sort of
um
sort of a
income so they need to be taxed um
um you have uh suggested that this
windfall go to the families that are
experiencing hardship in greatest
difficulty i think we need to uncouple
the gas and electricity markets as you
suggested in order to avoid excessive
costs for businesses and households in
the future and you talk about laying a
foundation for european strategy when it
comes to greater sovereignty and
autonomy when it comes to energy
madam
president
the european uh council and all those
who've spoken out recently need to show
the same diligence or speed of execution
because uh we're faced with urgency the
need to support ukraine but also an
urgent need to support all european
citizens so that they can believe in a
stronger united europe uh benoit benoit
blue card
blue card
can you accept a blue card will you
respond maria
thank you dear colleague i have a
question for you are you satisfied are
you satisfied
by the way the president of the
commission
described this new disconnection between
the natural gas price and the price of
electricity should we not give more
details because we need more investments
i'm going to go to thessaloniki tomorrow
and i have to explain to them solidarity
what is it going to mean in practice
over this very harsh winter all the
measures that were
proposed today by the commission have
already been adopted by greece so when
is the next step coming and how fast is
it going to be here
indeed i think we need more details on
these of uncoupling i think it's a good
thing indeed there's uncoupling the
illicit electricity that's produced not
from gas shouldn't uh
uh
be impacted to the same extent in terms
of uh
firms and households i think that is a
good decision
so that we are not forced and that's why
we're trying to what we're trying to
correct by taxing energy companies so
that we can
see a move towards the renewables but
there was a big colossal profits in a
justified way you should be
called upon to contribute but i think
we should call on commission and council
to provide the details of these
proposals but i think the objectives
have been sort of laid down by the
president of the commission and i think
they are a step in the right direction
when it comes to supporting uh
businesses households and all in society
for one minute
thank you president
at the beginning of the month many
people know they won't reach the end of
the month with any money in their
account and this is a situation faced by
far too many europeans that's part of
the deadly reality and this eats away at
them inside
the dutch government has failed to
demonstrate the urgency necessary to
tackle the cost of living crisis
when it comes to ruta for government
they're simply behind the times and this
is something we can't afford
at the present time
i think we have to be honest we have to
admit that this cost of living crisis
might lead to a recession
and a recession could then provide a
feeding ground for unrest and for
populist parties this is why madam
present to the commission
i would appeal to plead don't allow this
to happen
encourage member states
to act immediately
so as to respect european standards when
it comes to decent measures such as a
minimum
salary minimum wage
we have to ensure that we have permanent
programs to do this
so as to keep
employment levels high while not
threatening companies catch the eye we
have five minutes we have many many
requests so i will give
one minute to five colleagues in the
order in which we receive them first is
maria walsh
madam president i very much welcome
a new mental health initiative through a
citizens panel
this is an incredibly important and a
positive step forward following our
future of europe conference
following the impact of kovidge the
stresses of isolation
and the war that we are all living
through
we must through an eu year of education
and training and a citizens panel
dedicated to mental health really look
at and finally understand the root
causes of mental health and how it's
impacting all facets of a person's life
especially our young people
you mentioned smes
madam president we know from research
that an employee
is more productive over 30 days more
productive
if an employer looks at their well-being
and the mentality that they have that is
sustainability
let's together deliver a citizens panel
and prepare for a 2024 eu year dedicated
to mental health thank you very much
madam president
thank you very much uh is costas
mavrides here
okay we go to the next request margarita
marquez
yes
president thank you very much and thank
you to president vonderlion for your
statement on the state of the union
during your presentation you listed a
series of new initiatives a european
hydrogen bank a european sovereignty
fund a new program for smes
also an initiative for mental health and
then other various initiatives in the
area of energy
and by providing further capacity for
the civil protection mechanism so my
question is as follows
if we
move forward with a proposal for
reviewing the mff
um how is that going to deal with
transferring all those initiatives into
the budget secondly you also listed
various principles
so that we could review the budgetary
rules and obviously these have to be
aligned with the principles adopted by
the parliament last year
so when
are we going to have the legislative
initiatives which will actually open the
door to for us to be able to revise
these rules about months
thank you madam president
miss vandalia thank you very much for
your address today
once again
you showed that the european union has a
human face you spoke with great courage
about the system in ukraine
and we support you when it comes to
european sanctions and i think we all
very much agree when it comes energy
price ceilings
uh
income support but i would like to have
had a bit more information on the
timeline a strict timetable this is what
our citizens want
we hope that you can come forward with
some details on a very strict timeline
over the next few days
so don't take this badly but i'm
surprised i know i know you very well
that you haven't spoken at all about the
european defense union
i take this as uh by this i mean the
european army
so perhaps you could give us some hope
with that we need the european defense
union another point miss fonda line
we've had the convention we've had
citizens panels
we've seen them put forward fantastic
proposals
so we should build on the convention if
we want europe to occupy an important
place in the world we have to do do away
with unanimous unanimity principle
please support that
mr buttercoffee you asked to take the
floor
for president from the line
madam president uh thunder lion there
are two topics that i'd like to raise
that you touched upon in your address
first global gateway
the unsolved governance issues that have
to do with the gateway
initiative will they be clarified before
the end of the year
and what about the um
the various projects are going to be uh
identified between now and the end of
the year and what about uh cooperation
with our connectivity partners uh japan
and india and then
on
policies with regard to china are we
drawing the right consequences from our
experience with russia xi jinping's
regime is becoming increasingly
repressive internally and more dangerous
externally china is supporting russia's
aggression in ukraine and quite openly
so what steps do you uh think of taking
in order to support taiwan to a greater
extent and to
support human rights policy in the
respect of xinhuan rather than
playing down madame bashley's criticism
and ensuring greater realism in the
economic sector in terms of our
relations with china yes
[Applause]
mrs van der leyen
all your announcements to tackle the
energy crisis
are much delayed
generalizations
and inadequate words and at the same
time
very few are making huge profits
at the same time as
the majority of households and
businesses and citizens are suffering
but also workers that see
inflation
skyrocketing
and eating up their incomes you have to
tell us
in what way when and with what results
will
you decouple the electricity prices from
natural gas
you have to explain to us
how when and
in
what way
the
windfall
tax will be applied to
corporations producing electricity and
also tell us how come
how is it possible for all these
announcements to be funded with a budget
which is only one percent of the
european gdp and i haven't seen any
stock taking on what you've acted
on
all these nice words you announced you
announced last year you've been head of
the commission for more than three years
three years and the budget is
insufficient
it's to respond
thank you very much honorable members
and madam president for this very lively
debate
and first of all i want to thank you for
the broad and united support for the
support we're giving to ukraine this was
overwhelmingly the case here in the
european parliament i know your staunch
supporter of ukraine and i thank you
that you reiterated it today with all
force
so um
to a few topics i will not be able to
respond to all the questions that have
been put forward i've spoken long
i want to have a look at the topic of
the energy crisis
and i want to make very sure that there
is no doubt about the fact in this house
that it is putin who triggered this
energy crisis
i had this
i made the strange experience that i
listened to an
id mep
who really
seemed at least to be so naive to think
that putin started to use gas as a
weapon only on the 24th of february of
this year
this has been prepared since long
i mean beg your pardon but look into the
last year where you could have seen
systematically gus from state-owned
russian state-owned company reduced the
deliveries of gas so that we had the 10
years low of gas storage are you so
naive or you do just want to ignore the
facts if you look at that
then uh i heard from
an mep of renew rightly so
that
the energy measures that we proposed
yesterday and that i explained today
have to be time limit
limited and of course they are time
limited because this is the reason why
we use the one two two to be speed up to
be time limited it is the emergency
instrument i know it is not highly
valued in the european parliament i
understand that but if you look at the
one to two explicitly the topic of
energy is mentioned in one two two so
and one of the preconditions
to the question here is it must be
appropriate it must be speedy and it
must be time limited it's a logic in
itself
you have asked hilda about
timelines
indeed the proposals we've put on the
table yesterday we hope and expect that
council will decide on them
end of september so that then they can
be on the road exactly but and this is
important the big big reform many of you
were rightly so calling to for
for example to decouple the gas from the
married order system this big reform
will be coming at the end of the year
and this is a big task all of us have to
tackle together before this mandate ends
because it is urgent now to move forward
with the completely changed energy
markets
on defense
i understand
your request
may i remind ourselves on that we've
done a lot to create the army of the
europeans so structures are in place the
pesco is in place the defense fund is in
place what we have to do now is bring it
on the road and deliver i know i'm
partially preaching in the wrong church
here because my my uh my call has to go
to the member state but there is a
reason why we put all these instruments
in place so let's work on it together
this should be now our task um to the
mep beauty cover
global gateway and the whole
topic of how to deal with china so first
of all global gateway
i think this deserves an own debate
because yes of course the governance has
to be in the place but i told you that
with president biden we will
invite leaders to a summit to go through
these projects now and to be very
concrete on where we deliver together
these investments that are a concrete
alternative what to what the world has
seen so far from china they are
transparent they are high quality and
they don't leave the member the
countries that um in which these
projects are finances with a huge debt
burden what the chinese projects always
do so what china is concerned
this too needs a known um an own debate
but the fact
that
a few weeks
before russia started the invasion
in ukraine
china and russia signed a contract of
unlimited friendship
this is telling enough
and finally honorable members i thank
you for the broad support to strengthen
our smes
um
we will come forward with the package as
i said i would be very happy to hear not
only what should not be
but please to hear also what we can do i
think this positive constructive
approach towards these reforms that we
want to look forward and that we want to
address this has to come to i think this
is a noble task of the commission and of
this parliament and finally
to fortify our democracies i got the
question
here on for example when are you acting
on forced labor in our products the good
news is yesterday we tabled a proposal
to combat forced labor so this is done
it now goes towards you and i hope um
that we will be there too united and
swift long live europe thank you very
much for very lively thank you
thank you very much
now we will do the last round of the
political group starting with thomas
deutsch for one minute
madam president
europe is in an energy crisis
energy prices have rocketed and
the provision of energy has become
uncertain
therefore companies are going bankrupt
and the citizens are facing
enormous bills
the response steps that the commission
has taken have not been have not brought
fruit
in
in fact
they have
weakened the
european economy
and during the summer while gas prices
and and electricity prices were so
rocket were rocketing the um
commission didn't do anything our only
response was to introduce new sanctions
which will reduce further
um natural gas supplies which is an
absurd idea when we're looking into the
winter now so we've heard a proposal
that european families who will be
unable to pay their bills should send
the bills to russia to moscow for the
russians to pay them well these
sanctions have backfired and led to an
increased inflation and the commission
has not done anything has not solved the
problem so europeans will send their
bills to brussels
[Applause]
response or reply that you gave me
was to ask european citizens to send
their bills to vladimir putin sorry is
that all that you have to say to the
millions of people who don't manage to
make ends
meet at the end of the month yes you can
shout me down colleagues that i'm proud
to represent here people who are
struggling rather than shareholders
is that what you have to say to people
who are struggling send your bills to
putin
uh of course vladimir putin is the only
uh person responsible for the terrible
war in ukraine but you are responsible
to europe citizens and you cannot just
hide yourself behind putin your role is
to provide specific answers and you said
yourself the energy markets don't work
the energy market doesn't work there
have been massive profits made by energy
companies on the backs of ordinary
people
um
we say that electricity
wouldn't have
increased as much as gas and we would
have been able to sort of offset the
crisis those are eight programs brought
in by countries but you know
uh very well
that you shouldn't uh
hide
behind
these
proposals and
uh by sort of uh taxing uh ordinary
citizens i think these kind of matters
will be more successful than sending out
two bins to putin
[Applause]
president
dear colleagues president of the
commission once again i just like to
recall the words of president vonda lyon
and that is you should have heard
listened to poland
earlier on
and
i think all member states have to take
the courage so that they can take a look
at what's going on in the european union
and uh so that we can have mutual
support
we need this
valor this courage and we have to show
unity and we have to learn the lessons
and the conclusions that from the
mistakes that the german government made
at the time thank you marco campo
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you madam president
thank you president vanderlaan i'd also
like to thank you for the
time you spent with us today
unlike many of your predecessors or
colleagues you've been with us from the
beginning to the end i'd like to say
that as far as the opposition parties
are concerned we very much appreciate
that
we're very much aware of the facts and
i'm sure you are too that we've
supported sanctions
now the time has come for us to start
trying to ask who's responsible for
what's happened
as you said
we have to learn from what's happened
with russia so as to avoid future
confrontations with china and that's a
real risk now
the there are whole series important
issues we have to continue to work on
the stability fact is one we also very
serious problem risk in terms of
competitivity
we have one country china i mentioned
them again which has been
hoarding raw materials in enormous
quantities
which is still opening up hundreds of
coal mines you talked about the ceramic
sector i was delighted to talk about
that on from italy but this is one of
the areas which has never been supported
or defended in eu trade policies we need
less rhetoric and more transparency on
the question of the mediterranean italy
has often been sidelined in the face of
the ongoing emergency there for one
minute go ahead
things are difficult
but what we need now is the message of
yes
we see all the difficulties that
everyone is facing
yes
we are doing whatever we can to make
things better
yes
we will get through this very difficult
time together there is light at the end
of the tunnel
and yes europe is a vital part
of the solution and for that we need
action now from the commission
from the council and from this house one
opportunity lies just ahead of you with
a vote on renewables and on energy
efficiency and i hope we will do the
right thing thank you so much
thank you very much scott next is stefan
sejune for one minute
[Applause]
merci madam the president
thank you madam president
i might be a little bit more explicit
than you have been in terms of the
statements made here in this house mr
baldela i'm sorry your statement was
irresponsible irresponsible because
there's not sanctions
that have caused the problem it's you
and the russians
you for years have had ties with uh
russian powers that be and today you're
lecturing us on what we should be doing
at a european level
as i said in my statement madam
president we need to deal with the issue
of interference
uh the money that's being paid to
political parties by the kremlin is a
real issue when it comes to independence
and sovereignty in europe
and we need to take up these issues and
i count on the commission
there too in order to uh start work
on that and a message to our italian
colleagues on this debate within the
debate
uh
sorry but we don't have the same ideas
as you do sorry about that but
that is not yet cast as far as the
italian elections are concerned i want
an italy that is open uh to europe open
to the wider world
and of course we will respect by the
results in italy but allow us to
campaign uh
what we're trying to do here is a
campaign on european issues and campaign
against your ideas sorry about that
i give the floor next to miss garcia
perez
one minute gracias president
thank you very much we've had a very
intense debate all of us have been able
to give our opinion we've been able to
listen to everybody's comments
there was something that hasn't been
present in the debate and i would have
liked to have seen this in the debate
and that is that we have far more
discussion about the social dimension of
europe
that part of europe that has to make
progress to support those who are most
in need
we need a kind of social resilience
package in order to tackle issues
uh these kind of issues so we need a per
a standing employment instrument so that
people
do not lose their trust in the european
project because i don't think we can
allow our european citizens to feel that
they've been left behind on the wayside
so all of us
have to continue to build the europe
social europe and europe of the citizens
thank you
next and finally manfred webber
well i also want to thank ozil from the
line for the contribution for the great
speech and the great discussion today
there's a broad consensus about now
activating going further
social means also creating jobs that's
why i think we have a lot in common
where we want to work on
but i want especially to thank ska
keller because she was presenting to the
epp the flowers that we are the founding
fathers of today's european union you
said it was adenauer it's the gasparilli
schumann christian democrats together
with socialists together as liberals and
then finally all the greens when you
grew up as a party contributed to this i
want blood but i want to say one thing
when we speak about pro-europeans and
not pro-europeans
we should not politicize this thing
because i tell you no please listen
please
please listen
in the spanish in the spanish government
there is podemos three spanish podemos
ministers voted against the membership
of finland and sweden in the nato three
of them in a government with the
socialists
we have the five stars
we have the five stars in government
five stars in government with lego in
italy nobody did a debate here nobody
asked for a debate here and this was
taking place in italy i'll give you
another argument
diaskar you had a coalition in france to
do together campaigning with melanchol
melonsho publicly said okay melanchol
publicly said that we don't respect any
more european law if we come in office
that was the position of melancholy so
what i wanted to say and i'll give you
another point in the last cop okay get a
debate about bulgaria
you will have repaid on bulgaria
two independent churches dear friends
now it's really it's really serious two
independent churches in bulgaria
independent churches in bulgaria seda
was a summer time thank you that
detaining
the opposition leader in bulgaria was
unlawfully and i was simply asking for a
debate about the bulgarian rule of law
situation thank you but that was refused
by the greens so thank you politicize
things when we talk about rule of law
it's not independent it's about based on
facts and not about particularly
orientation
dear colleagues
dear colleagues
[Applause]
for those of you
commenting about the time
if you had been sitting here
for four hours now you would have known
that nobody was stopped from speaking in
this chamber and i will not stop now
i have a few announcements that i would
like to make before we go to the vote
the debate is now finished on this
on this state of the union thank you
commission president thank you for the
time that you spent with us for the
whole time thank you